witnesses william barr has served as the
attorney general of the united states
since february 14 2019
having previously served in the same
position from 1991 to 1993
under president george h.w bush
he also served as deputy attorney
general and assistant attorney general
of the office of legal counsel under the
bush administration
was a member of the domestic policy
staff under president reagan
served in the central intelligence
agency and was a law
clerk for judge malcolm wilkie of the
u.s court of appeals for the d.c circuit
in addition to his significant public
service he also has extensive experience
practicing law in the private sector
attorney general barr received his a b
and m a from columbia
university and a jd from george
washington university
school of law we welcome the attorney
general and we thank him for
participating today
now if you would please rise i will
begin by swearing you in
would you raise your right hand please
or left hand
do you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury that the testimony you're about
to give is true and correct to the best
of your knowledge information and belief
so help you god at the record show the
witness has answered in the affirmative
thank you and please be seated
please note that your written statement
will be entered into the record in its
entirety
accordingly i ask that you summarize
your testimony in five minutes
to help you stay within that time there
is a timing light on your table
when the light switches from greed to
yellow you have one minute to conclude
your testimony
when the light turns red it signals your
five minutes have expired
mr barr you may begin
good morning mr chairman ranking member
jordan
i'm pleased to be here this morning on
behalf of the department of justice i
want to pay my respects
to your colleague congressman john lewis
an indomitable
champion of civil rights and the rule of
law
i think it is especially important to
remember today
that he pursued his cause passionately
and successfully with
unwavering commitment to non-violence
as i said in my confirmation hearing the
attorney general has a unique obligation
he holds and trusts the fair and
impartial administration of justice
he must ensure that there is one
standard of justice that applies to
everyone equally
and that criminal cases are handled
even-handedly
based on the law and the facts and with
regard
without regard to political or personal
considerations
and i can tell you that i've handled
criminal matters that have come to me
for decision
in this way the president has not
attempted to interfere in these
decisions
on the contrary he has told me from the
start that he expects me to exercise
my independent judgment to make whatever
call i think is right and that is
precisely what i've done
indeed it's precisely because i feel
complete freedom to do what i think is
right
that induced me to serve once again as
attorney general
as you just said mr chairman i served as
attorney general under president george
h.w
bush and after that i spent many years
in the corporate world
i'm almost 70 years old i was almost 70
years old and slipping happily into
retirement
i had nothing to prove and i had no
desire to return to government
i had no prior relationship with
president trump
let me turn briefly to the several
pressing issues of the day
the horrible killing of george floyd
minneapolis understandably
jarred the whole country and forced us
to reflect on long-standing issues in
the nation
those issues obviously relate to the
relationship between law enforcement
and the african-american community given
our history it's understandable that
among black americans there's
be some ambivalence and often distrust
toward the police
until just last 50 years ago
or so our laws were insta
institutions were explicitly racist
explicitly discriminatory it was not
until the 60s that the civil rights
movement finally succeeded in tearing
down the jim crow edifice
our laws finally came to formally embody
the guarantee of equal protection
and since then the work of securing
civil rights has rightly focused
on reforming institutions to ensure they
better
conform to our laws and to our
aspirations
that work it's important to acknowledge
has been increasingly
successful police forces today are far
more diverse than they've ever been
and there are both more black police
chiefs and more black
officers in the ranks although the death
of george floyd
at the hands of the police was a
shocking event the fact is that
these events are fortunately quite rare
according to statistics compiled by the
washington post the number of unarmed
black men killed by police so far this
year is eight
the number of unarmed white men killed
by police over the same period
of time as eleven and the overall
numbers of police shootings have been
decreasing
nevertheless every instance of excessive
force
is unacceptable and must be addressed
appropriately through legal process
as is happening now in minneapolis but
apart from the numbers i think these
events strike a deep
accord in the black community because
they are
perceived as manifestations of a deeper
lingering concern than it encounters
with police
blacks will not be treated even-handedly
they will not be given the benefit of
the doubt they will be treated with
greater suspicion
senator tim scott has recounted the
numerous times he's been unjustifiably
pulled over
on capitol hill and as one prominent
black professional in washington said to
me
african americans often feel treated as
suspects first and citizens second
and i think these concerns are
legitimate
at the same time i think would be an
oversimplification to treat the problem
as rooted in some deep-seated
racism generally infecting our police
departments
it seems far more likely that the
problem stems from a complex mix of
factors which can be addressed
with focused attention over time and we
in law enforcement must be conscious of
the concerns
and ensure that we do not have two
systems
of justice
unfortunately some have chosen to
respond to george floyd's death
in a far less productive way by
demonizing the police promoting slogans
like all cops or bastard
and making grossly irresponsible pro
proposals to fund the police
the demonization of the police is not
only unfair and inconsistent with
principles of
all people should be treated as
individuals but gravely injurious
to the inner city communities
when communities turn on and hillary the
police
officers naturally become more
risk-averse and crime rates soar
unfortunately we are seeing that now in
many of our cities
the threat to black lives posed by crime
on the streets
is massively greater than any threat
posed by police misconduct
the leading cause of death for young
black males is homicide
every year approximately 7 500 black
americans are victims of homicide
the mass the vast majority of them
around 90 percent
are killed by other blacks mainly by
gunfire each of those lives matter
it is for this reason than in selected
cities where
there has been an upsurge in violent
crime we are stepping up and bolstering
the activities of our joint anti-crime
task forces
finally i want to address a different
breakdown in the rule of law
that we've witnessed over the past two
months
in the wake of george floyd's death
violent rioters and anarchists
have hijacked legitimate protests
to wreak senseless havoc and destruction
on innocent victims
the current situation in portland is a
telling example
every night for the past two months a ma
of hundreds of rioters have laid siege
to the federal courthouse
and other nearby federal property the
rioters
have come equipped for fight armed with
powerful slingshots
tasers sledge hammers saws knives rifles
and explosive devices
inside the courthouse are a relatively
small number of federal law enforcement
personnel
charged with defense of the defensive
mission
to protect the courthouse what unfolds
nightly around the courthouse cannot
reasonably be called protest it is by
any objective measure
and assault on the government of the
united states
as elected officials of the federal
government every member of this
committee regardless of your political
views or your feelings about the trump
administration
should condemn violence against federal
officers
and the destruction of federal property
thank you mr chairman
and i appreciate your
listening for me the areas of concern in
your opening
statement and i'm looking forward to
addressing them all
thank you for your testimony we will now
proceed under the five-minute rule with
questions
and i will recognize myself for five
minutes
on july 22nd you joined the president as
he announced the expansion of operation
legend
initiative
let me start that again on july 22nd
you joined the president as he announced
the expansion of operation legend
an initiative to combat violent crime in
kansas city
with approximately 61 million dollars in
doj grants
i am confused however as to the purpose
of launching operation legend
at this moment in time in december of
last year you announced that the
department
would divert over 70 million dollars in
grants to seven u.s cities
under an initiative called operation
relentless pursuit
correct that's right and operation
relentless
pursuit targeted a familiar list of
cities places like albuquerque
baltimore and kansas city correct
correct
at the same july 22nd press conference
you initially claimed that over 200
arrests had been
have been made under operation legend
correct correct
and that but you misspoke correct the
u.s attorney's office to the western
district of missouri
later confirmed that only a single
arrest had been made under the auspices
of
operation legend correct i don't know
and the other and the 199 other arrests
were made
under relentless pursuit or other
programs
well that was correct i think you could
be forgiven for being confused
operation legend appears to be little
more than a repackaging of existing
operations in these cities so why all
the drama
why join the president the white house
to announce a bold new operation
that appears to be neither bold nor new
understandably americans are very
suspicious of your motives here
there are those who believe you are
sending federal law enforcement into
these cities
not to combat violent crime but to help
with the president's re-election efforts
the president has made clear that he
wants con that he wants conflict
between protesters and police to be
essential claim
a central theme of his campaign so let
me ask you directly mr barr
yes or no yes or no did you rebrand
existing
projects under the legend in order to
assist the president in an election year
i wouldn't i would attorney general
would you agree with me at least on
principle
that it is improper for the department
of justice to divert resources and law
enforcement personnel
in an effort to assist the president's
re-election campaign no
mr chairman in the fall we did
inaugurate an
anti-crime initiative because we were
concerned
about increasing violent crime in a
number of cities
and we call that relentless pursuit
unfortunately covin intervened
and our agents who were detailed for
these assignments could not
perform uh the operation so the
operation
was squelched by kovid
so we couldn't complete or make much
progress on relentless
pursuit however in the intervening time
we saw a violent crime continuing to
rise and a lot of that was triggered by
the events
after uh the death of george floyd
so we did reboot the program
after covid started breaking and our
we could commit to law enforcement
resources to actually accomplish
uh the mission which is to reduce
violent crime
now i regret that kovit interrupted our
law enforcement activities but it
doesn't obviate the fact
that there's serious violent crime in
these cities these police
and and mayors from have been asking us
for help
and we have put in additional federal
agents and investigators to help deal
with it
have you now yes or no have you
discussed the president's re-election
campaign with the president
or with any white house official or any
surrogate of the president
well i'm not going to get into my
discussions with the president well have
you discussed that topic with him yes or
no
not not in relation to this program i
didn't ask that yes if you discussed
that i'm a member of the cabinet and
there's an election going on obviously
the topics
yes well the topic comes up in cabinet
meetings and other things
okay it shouldn't be a surprise that the
topic of the election
i didn't say i was surprised i just
asked if you've done that so as part of
those conversations with the president
or his people about the re-election
campaign have you ever discussed the
current or future deployment of federal
law enforcement
in connection with what in connection
with what you just said in connection
with the
with your discussions with the president
or with other people around him
of his re-election campaign have you
discussed
the current or future and deployment of
federal law enforcement as i say i'm not
going to get into my discussions with
the president
but i've made it clear that i would like
to pick the cities based on law
enforcement need and based on neutral
criteria but you you can't tell me
whether you discussed
no i'm not going to discuss what i
discussed can you commit today
that the department will not use federal
law enforcement as a prop in the
president's re-election campaign
i just want to close with this thought
you really can't hide behind legal
fictions this time mr barr
it's all out in the open whether people
can see what you are doing for
themselves
the president wants footage for his
campaign ads
and you appear to be serving it up to
him as ordered
in most of these cities the protests had
begun to wind down
before you marched in and confronted the
protesters and the protesters
aren't mobs they are mothers and
veterans
and mayors in this moment real
leadership would entail de-escalation
collaboration and looking for ways to
peaceably resolve our differences
instead you use pepper spray and
truncheons on american citizens
you did it here in washington you did it
lafayette square
you expanded to portland and now you are
projecting fear
and violence nationwide in pursuit of
obvious political objectives
shame on you mr barr can i just say no
shame on you can i just my time has
expired
for what purpose does mr jordan see
recognition
my time is expired what purpose is mr uh
mr johnson johnson seek recognition
questions for the witness and i will
yield the floor to him to respond
mr chairman you've conflated two
different things the the
the effort like legend uh is
to deal with violent crime crime that's
committing on the streets of the city
again predatory violence like murder
shootings
which are soaring in some cities right
now
that does not involve encountering
protesters as you refer to it
civil disturbance is a different set of
issues
and i i just reject the idea that the
department has flooded anywhere and
and attempted to suppress demonstrators
we make a clear distinction between
demonstrators
this is my time and and you know the
fact of the matter is if you take
portland portland the courthouse is
under attack
the federal resources are inside the
perimeter around the courthouse
defending it from
almost two months of daily attacks
where people march to the court tried to
gain entrance and have set fires
thrown things used explosives
and injured police including
just this past weekend perhaps
permanently blinding three federal
officers with lasers we are on the
defense it's
we're not out looking for for trouble
and if the
state and the city would provide the law
enforcement services that other
jurisdictions
do we would have no need to have
additional
marshals in the courthouse on behalf of
hundreds of millions of americans thank
you for that clarification and thank you
for being here and thank you for your
service today
and your willingness to do this in very
challenging times
mr attorney general we're very
appreciative it's not an easy job
it's a vitally important one i so
appreciated what you said in your
opening statement today which is what
you said in your confirmation hearing
the attorney general has a unique
obligation he must he holds and trusts
the fair and impartial administration of
justice we appreciate that so much
the democrats have asserted here this
morning and they continue to say in the
media that
under your leadership the justice
department has become highly politicized
why is that a totally unfounded
allegation
because actually what i've been trying
to do is restore the rule of law and the
rule of law
is at essence that we have one rule for
everybody if you apply
one rule to a the same rule applies to b
and i felt we didn't have that
previously at the department we had
strayed
and i would just ask people
supposedly punishing the president's
enemies and helping his
friends what enemies have i indicted
who who could you point to one
indictment that has been under the
department that you feel
is is unmerited that you feel
violates the rule of law one indictment
now you say i help the president's
friends
the cases that are cited the stone case
and the fling case
both cases where i determined uh that
some intervention was necessary to
rectify the rule of law to make sure
people are treated the same
i said although stone was prosecuted
under me
and i said all along i thought that was
a righteous prosecution
i thought he should go to jail and i
thought the judge's sentence was correct
but the lying prosecutors were trying to
advocate for a sentence that was more
than
twice anyone else in a similar position
had ever served and this is a 67 year
old
man first-time offender no violence and
they were trying to put him in jail for
seven to nine years
and i wasn't going to advocate that
because that is not the rule of law
i agree the president's friends don't
deserve special breaks
but they also don't deserve to be
treated more harshly than other people
and sometimes
that's a difficult decision to make
especially when you know you're going to
be castigated for it
but that is what the rule of law is and
that's what fairness to the individual
ultimately comes to
being being willing to do what's fair
to the individual amen and thank you for
that and by contrast what the previous
doj did under the previous
administration was politicized law
enforcement
the obama biden administration sabotaged
the trump transition
they illegally spied on the trump
campaign they unmasked members of the
trump campaign
they employed aggressive tactics on
their on their campaign officials
senior fbi officials we all know on this
committee carried over
from the obama administration carried on
their abuses into the trump
administration and into the
whole impeachment scam and all the rest
let me ask you just one question
because my time is running out president
obama's attorney general eric holder
famously referred to himself as
president obama's wingman
he said in an interview quote i'm still
enjoying what i'm doing there's still
work to be done
i'm still the president's wingman so i'm
there with my boy that's what he said
famously
is it the duty of the attorney general
to be the president's wingman
no i've already described what i think
the duty of the attorney general
is and and in your office you are then
free to act independently of the
president isn't that true
that is true particularly on criminal
cases it's required
and that's exactly what he has asked you
to do is that right yes
i have no further amount yield back
thank you thank you as well you have no
further questions your time is expired
uh ms lofgren uh thank you mr chairman
mr trippy general
it's obvious uh what is happening here
uh from the video
played during the renting limber's
remarks
it's clear that the president's playbook
is divert attention from his
catastrophic
failure in dealing with the covet 19
association in canada our neighbor to
the north
in europe the virus has been reduced to
such a level
that people can safely go out and not
worry about being infected but here in
the united states
millions of americans have been infected
tens of thousands are dying and
the president needs to divert from that
failure
and is the playbook the playbook is to
create
the impression that there is violence
that he must send in federal troops
and that the american people should be
afraid
of other americans and trust the
president because he's going to send
all troops to american cities
and that's how he hopes to win the
election you know
it's one thing to fight crime joint task
forces that
involves the cooperation
of state and local officials but the
governor of oregon
and the mayor of portland has asked that
the federal troops leave
because the reaction has actually
been uh in in reverse proportion
people are showing up because the troops
are there
and i'd like to say that so many of them
i would say
most of them are uh non-violent
we've all heard about the wall of bombs
the wall of moms who show up
to make sure that people are safe and
here's what they say
they say they've been tear gassed night
after night
left vomiting that they've been shot at
with raw
bean bags pepper spray so this brutality
has created
even more demonstrators i just like to
ask you this
when the president issued his executive
order
they indicated your department should
prioritize investigations
has your uh department started in the
investigations
so to the executive order that the
president issued
which executive order congresswoman the
executive order
that uh asked for the deployment of uh
troops to uh protect the monuments and
the federal
facilities yes i'm june 26th
yeah i wouldn't say it was troops but
the the the uh
we have initiated investigations yes
we've made arrests i have
people who have who have been rioting
and taking down
uh uh statues but i i think your
your characterization of portland is
completely false
like this i would like to we can get
into that but i'd like to ask you a
question about surveillance if i may
uh we reports that cell site stimulators
known as stingrays or dirt boxes
are being used to collect phone call
location
and even the content of phone calls
phones are being used that will have
face recognition or cell phones
technology and that there is bulk
collection
of internet browsing history what
specific
authority is the department using for
these surveillance tools i really can't
speak to the to those instances if if
they've
in fact occurred i'm glad to go and try
to determine what you're talking about
actually i'm asking about authority not
uh the
the details well you know i think
most of our cyber activities are
conducted by the fbi under their law
enforcement
powers to detect and prevent crime
federal crime i think the american
public should know
that this surveillance technique is
just about the people in you know in
front of the courthouse
if a husband and wife call each other
and one of the
uh spouses has a cell phone that's
within range
of one of these uh technologies
not only the location the actual content
of that couple's conversation can be
scooped up
using this technology so this really
isn't just about
demonstrating this is about the privacy
of
all americans and it's all being
violated
for the president's political purposes
of trying to
create a scene create a reason
divert attention from the clothing
safely
i think it's really very important and
a disservice to the american people mr
chairman my time is expired so
yeah they don't want to order dental
lady yields back
mr chairman point of order real quick
i'm gonna state his point of order
could you ask those members who choose
not to come to work to silence their
cell phones on the video because it's
distracting
to what we're doing here today that is
not a point of order
the uh the uh i now recognize uh
mr chabot mr attorney general would it
be accurate to say that it's this
administration's responsibility and of
course you're part of the administration
to see that federal laws are upheld and
that the federal
property uh is secure and safe
and protected is that correct that's
right congressman
they're sort of distinct missions one
mission is to enforce federal law
and by the way the federal government is
the sovereign of the united states we
have two sovereigns here
in the united states and we enforce the
federal law all over the country every
square foot of the country
we enforce federal law the other is
protecting federal property
and specifically u.s courthouses which
are the heart of federal property and
all 93 jurisdictions in the united
states
and we have the obligation to to protect
federal courts and the u.s marshals
specifically
have been given that obligation federal
courts are under attack since when is it
okay
to try to burn down a federal court
if someone went down the street to the
prettiman court here that beautiful
courthouse we have right at the bottom
of the hill
and started breaking windows and firing
industrial grade fireworks in to start a
fire
throw kerosene balloons in and and start
fires in the court
is that okay is that okay now
no the u.s marshals have a duty to stop
that and defend
the courthouse and that's what we are
doing in portland we are
at the courthouse defending the
courthouse we're not out looking for
trouble
thank you general and as far as weapons
and devices that were utilized by the
group of people
and you mentioned trying to destroy the
courthouse i mean they were literally
trying to burn it
down and apparently didn't
give a hoot about the people that were
occupied in the building as well so
people were in danger that is absolutely
right
so as far as the the weapons that you
mentioned let me get this straight
um my understanding is that the people
attacking the building had
among other things rifles explosives
knives
saws sledgehammers tasers
slingshots rocks bricks
lasers have i missed anything or does
that about cover it
you have missed some things but that's a
that's a good list
but you know they have these powerful
slingshots with ball bearings that they
shoot they've used pellet guns
we believe we have found uh those uh
projectiles uh at both have penetrated
uh marshals to the bone uh
and they use the the lasers to blind the
to blind the marshals um
they do start fires they start fires if
they can get into the fire inside
or through the windows and they start
fires along the outside of the the pres
of the the courthouse when the marshals
come out to try to deal with the fire
they're assaulted
general if local elected officials
mayors
and city councils and governors did
their jobs and kept the peace
would it even be necessary for federal
law enforcement personnel to be there in
the first place
no and that's exactly the point look
around the country even where there are
these kinds of riots occurring
we don't we haven't had to put in the
kind of reinforcements
that we have in portland because the
state and local law enforcement does
their job
and won't allow riders to come and just
physically assault
the courthouse in portland that's not
the case
general some have derisively referred to
these
law enforcement personnel as
stormtroopers
and worse does that accurately describe
them
would you like to set the record
straight no they're obviously not
stormtroopers you know normally we would
have a group of deputy marshals in a
court that would be
you know in business suits and ties or
regular civilian dress those would be
the deputy marshals as the
protective force for the court but after
almost a month of rioting in portland
you know we sent
in i think it was around the 4th of july
a time frame we sent
in about 20 special operations
uh marshals uh and those are tactical
teams that are able you know or are
padded and protected so they could deal
with this kind of thing
up until last week i was told we had our
stormtrooper from the department of
justice amounted to 29 marshals
in the courthouse 29 marshals
as of la until recently increased i
think there were 95
i was told 95 dhs
federal protective service and other dhs
officers trying to protect the
courthouse and three other buildings
that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to protect federal functions and
federal buildings which are very small
part of the city
but the rioters go at them and and we
have gradually increased our numbers
there to try to protect
those uh those facilities if the state
would come in and and keep peace on the
streets
in front of the courthouse we wouldn't
need additional people at the courthouse
thank you general my times expire the
gentleman's time has expired uh mrs
jackson lee
mr chairman before i begin i'd like to
submit into the record a picture of
lewis and clark history department chair
shot at protests in portland
and unanimous consent place that into
the record
[Music]
john lewis in 1963 said we are tired
about
being beat by police we're tired of
being put in jail
we want our freedom now mr attorney
journal in your remarks you indicated
that we've made great progress since
that time
and you indicated that the killing of
george floyd was
shocking i disagree it was outright
cold-blooded murder on the streets of
america
unfortunately by police misconduct you
seem to have a difficult time
understanding systemic racism and
institutional racism
that has plagued so many mr attorney
general do you understand
a black mother's or parents talk
to their child to their son do you know
what that is
i think i do uh i don't know if you do
but
trayvon martin ahmed arbury tamir rice
michael brown sean bell
and george floyd black mothers and
fathers have had to talk to their sons
about
police violence i take no backseat to
the history of this committee that has
stood
for good policing not misconduct
and so i ask you this question does the
trump justice department seek to end
systemic racism and racism in law
enforcement i just need a yes or no
answer
to the extent there is racism in any of
our institutions in this country and the
police
then obviously this administration is
will fully enforce this so you agree
that there may be systemic racism
uh let me continue my line of
questioning don't agree that there's
systemic racism in the police department
specifically
generally in this country i'm reclaiming
my time mr general
specifically do you understand the
violent impact of racial profiling
and do you support the in racial
profiling uh racial and religious
profiling in the george floyd bill
including the removal of the strict
interpretation of qualified immunity
which would leave individuals like
brianna taylor and
george floyd without any relief at all
no i'm opposed to eliminating qualified
immunity and i don't agree that it would
leave
the victims of police misconduct well
let me share with you
some aspects without any remedy i'm
reclaiming my time let me share with you
some aspects of
uh profiling after the death of george
floyd found that while black people make
up 19
of the minneapolis population and nine
percent of its police they were on the
receiving end of 58
of the city's police use of force
incidents
in addition uh we've seen uh that uh
black men are twice as likely to be
stopped
and searched hispanic drivers 65 to
receive a ticket
uh and native americans in arizona three
times more likely
to search and be stopped let me ask you
the questions of how we respond to that
the justice department has many tools at
its proposals to reduce police violence
the patent or practice investigations
a practice to end bad policing and plot
and police violence it addresses police
violence at an institution level rather
than just focuses on acute cases
if you understand that then why has your
department only pursued
one pattern or practice investigation
since president trump
took office that could stop systemic
racism
the if you read my statement or listen
to my statement i i did
specifically acknowledge that uh there
was a difficulty in this country
uh with the african-american community
mr attorney journal i have short time
can you
tell me why you have not done a pattern
in practice
what was the reason uh and you asked me
what i thought the response was and i
thought the response to this
is in fact the training of police
uh and uh i think the police believe
that that's a response i was talking to
a black
then let me continue mr attorney general
i i want to respect you but i have a
short time
you you for example 18 usc section 242
which makes unlawful the denial of
rights under the color of law
can you defend the fact that in the
first seven months of fy 2020 federal
prosecutors
filed only 242 charges 242 charges in
just
27 cases in the trump doj
and were you aware uh that in fy 2019
federal prosecutors bought two
section 242 charges in just 49 cases in
the united states
and are you aware of how many cases
we've had 184
274 which means that in fy 2019 only
about 27
out of every 100 000 prosecutions was
related to section 20242
charges do you have a reason for that
yeah yes i do
i will get you the numbers on it i don't
know them off the top of my head but
actually our criminal prosecutions under
241 and 242
are are extremely strong and are
comparable to if not exceed prior
administrations but at the beginning of
this year
most of the very few jurisdictions had
grand juries that were open
no grand jury i think the reason is
because it was really skinny was not
your focus your focus was more to
let out friends like roger stone and
paul manafort
tamir rice whose case has not been taken
up was playing with a toy gun
was killed by police at the age of 12.
brianna taylor was sleeping in her
apartment when she was killed by police
at age 26
and rashad brooks 27 was killed just for
sleeping
uh in his car in a wendy's parking lot
and george floyd
from houston texas known as a humble man
was murdered
in the streets of minneapolis crying i
can't breathe
i would hope that the doj would focus on
systemic institutional racism
because there is good policing that's
what we're trying to do in the justice
and the judiciary committee
and that's what we need you to join us
on mr attorney general
and to recognize that institutional
racism does exist
and until we accept that we will not
finish our job and reach the goals and
aspirations
of our late iconic john lewis with that
i yield back
generally he goes back mr uh gomer
attorney general barr we've been hearing
about
these peaceful protests in major cities
around
the country controlled by democratic
mayors and city councils
you've had a lot of experience have you
ever
seen so many people
hurt injured and killed
at peaceful protests in your life
i i haven't seen it no not at a peaceful
protest uh
obviously as i've said from the
beginning these peaceful protests
in many places are being hijacked by a
very hardcore
of of uh instigators violent instigators
they they become violent and their
primary violence
direction of violence is to injure
police police
police casualties far exceed anything uh
on the civilian side yeah one weren't
there over 50
police injured in chicago just
in recent days and now i'm hearing this
allegation that this administration
is helping spread coronavirus
covet 19 and yet these are some of the
same people
that just castigated the president
for shutting down travel from the
location where the virus was coming from
and now it's something more interested
in defending
the chinese communist party than they
are our own country
but uh what occurred to me hearing this
allegation about this administration
helping spread covet uh
would it be a good idea then perhaps if
that's the big concern here
uh that maybe the federal government
should shut down
the protests during this covert 19
spread so that we can satisfy our
colleagues
that you're doing more to stop it
has that ever been a consideration no
i've never considered that
well it would apparently stop some of
the
allegations being thrown here uh now i
know you know history
uh going back to
1917 the bolshevik revolution the mao
revolution
uh some of these tactics we're seeing
are not new
trying to get even david horowitz i
introduced one time as a former social
he said no i was a full-blown communist
but he has pointed out that he started
looking away from
the group he was in because he saw they
were interested in trying to provoke the
police to kill somebody
so that they could really create mayhem
you're familiar with that tactic
by marxist or you're not yes
it is a dangerous time well let me ask
you uh
i know you know that uh
u.s attorneys are supposed to serve at
the pleasure of the president
you know bill clinton fired 93 u.s
attorneys on the same day
do you know what made u.s attorney
berman
think that he was the exception who did
not serve at the pleasure of the
president
what caused him to think he owned that
position
i think part of it was he seems to have
had the view that
because he was court appointed and there
is a provision in law for
court appointment of a u.s attorney is
essentially a placeholder until the
administration
uh gets somebody uh that he felt he
could not be removed by the president
because he was court appointed and
that's not correct yeah and
some um judges
failed to know what my constitutional
law professor
knew and that is that all courts
except federal courts except for one oh
their existence
and continuation and jurisdiction to the
u.s congress
uh hopefully uh mr berman will figure
that out at some point
now uh is brutes or
still working for the fbi
he works for the department of justice
uh well we have heard so much
information about
is basically being the go-between
between the dnc
the clinton campaign fusion gps
christopher steele
the russian propaganda that were
incorporated into his dossier
and i know kleinsmith
christopher wray indicated he had been
given the chance to resign go get a
better job
i'm wondering how long bruce ohr is
going to be staying where he
is it's incredible to me that he's still
there
well i can't talk about you know
individual personnel matters
well thank you for your service
i'm sorry for the abuse you've taken
when you're just trying to do your job
appreciate it very much
you're back the gentleman's time has
expired
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
tennessee for five minutes
thank you madam chair mr barr i'm the
chairman of the subcommittee on the
constitution civil rights and civil
liberties so this is most pertinent
hearing to me
firstly i'd like to ask you if you will
work with us and allow the head of the
civil rights division assistant attorney
general eric
dryband to testify before this committee
this fall
i'll talk to him about it we encourage
him
i'll talk to him about it all right i've
closely watched actions taken by the
federal government lafayette park in
june
and currently in portland oregon
according to a doj document dated june 4
received by this committee
1500 federal agents from 10 different
agencies were deployed to confront
protesters in washington d.c
at lafayette park which has long been
honored and accepted as a place of
protest in our nation's capital
on the first day of june the world
watched a horror on live television
as federal agents deployed by the
administration
and with you present and telling him to
get it done
used force to clear lafayette park so
that the president with you and others
at your side
could walk across the park and have a
photo op in front of saint john's church
this was anathema to the bishop of the
diocese and the rector of the church
it was also an affront to the
constitution and to the american people
giving the timing and the coordinated
attack against the peaceful
demonstrators it's strange credulity
that this was not planned
for use of political purposes and just
yesterday major demarco testified
to another committee of congress that
the protesters were peaceful
and that's what the most majority of
people have said
and the response was excessive
when did you first learn that the
president planned to walk through the
park and go to saint john's church
first i'd like to respond to what you
let would you please answer my question
my time is limited
i learned uh sometime in the afternoon
that the president
uh might come out of the white house and
then later in the afternoon i heard that
he might go over the church
so it was absolutely necessary the park
be clear for his for his well that's
that had nothing to do with that the
plan to move mr mr
plan necessary that the park be cleared
and it was done
and you said get it done i have the time
thank you
in portland we've seen mothers and we've
seen veterans who were peacefully
protesting
not threatening the federal courthouse
beaten and gassed
unidentified armed federal agents
violently attacked demonstrators in a
violation of the first amendment's
freedom of assembly
and arrested citizens without
individualized suspicion and a violation
of fourth amendment's protection against
unreasonable searches and seizures and
award requirement
you've gone through the fifth amendment
and due process and just negated
it and the tenth amendment which leads
general policing to the law enforcement
to the state has been forgotten maybe
what happened was your secret police
were poorly trained
just like your bureau of prisons guards
were poorly trained
and allowed the most notorious inmate
in our nation's last several years
jeffrey epstein
to conveniently commit suicide sad
you misled congress and the american
people about special counsel mueller's
findings with your quote summary and
quote of his report
it was issued about a month before you
released the
redacted portion of the mueller report
but you set the stage
you set the stage such that the special
counsel objected to the accuracy of how
it was reported by the press and what
you said
and federal judge reggie walton
appointed by george w
bush declared in a ruling that your
summary was quote distorted
unquote and misleading unquote and that
the court could not
trust you further judge walton stated
the report was quote a calculated
attempt to influence public disclosure
about the mueller report in favor of
president trump
unquote this committee still does not
have the unredacted mueller report
america has still not seen the
unredacted mueller report
your excuses for not releasing it
because it had to do with ongoing cases
no longer exists because those ongoing
cases
have been completed or commuted
or finished other
attorney generals work with this
judiciary committee to see that the
american public and that the judiciary
committee had
unredacted copies of that report you if
not you've gone to court to stall it
this report needs to be given to this
committee
and michael cohen you've treated him
differently than michael flynn
and roger stone and michael flynn you've
attempted to dismiss the charges even
after
twice pled guilty and in roger stone
you went further mr barr
john lewis said to us if not me
who if not now when that's why i
introduced hres 1032 which would require
this committee to investigate your
conduct as attorney general and
determine whether you should be
impeached
that is my constitutional duty i yield
back the balance of my time
may i respond to these i think
recognition
i'm sorry what did you i would like to
say i would like to seek recognition for
unanimous consent requests
yes thank you nice i'd like to introduce
for the record a slate article entitled
why trump chose portland which describes
the racial history of the state and the
portland police bureau
i'd also like to introduce an op-ed from
mary mccord who writes her words were
twisted to justify the department's
disingenuous position
to drop charges against michael flynn
after he had already pled guilty
i'd like to introduce an op-ed from
jonath jonathan kravis
describing the political interference in
the roger stone case and why he resigned
from the department of justice
and i'd like to introduce a statement
from over 2 600 former doj officials
calling for attorney general barr's
resignation because of his assault on
the rule of law
and a letter from the new york city bar
urging congress to commence formal
inquiries and a pattern of conduct by
attorney general barr
that threatens public confidence in the
fair and impartial administration of
justice
and finally a letter from 27 of the
district of columbia's most prominent
attorneys and law professors
including four past presidents of the
d.c bar calling for an ethics
investigation
into mr barr's conduct last but not
least a letter from over 80 percent of
the george washington university
law school faculty your alma mater
saying his actions have posed to
continue to create a clear and present
danger to the even-handed administration
of justice to civil liberties
and the constitutional okay without
objection
madam chair one more unanimous consent
request go ahead on the
this is the article that says
representative jerry nataler says antifa
violence in portland is a myth that's
from politico and a number of other
journalists
mr collins is recognized for five
minutes thank you madam chair welcome
attorney george wow
i'm beginning to believe frankly that
you're probably the just hadn't come out
yet probably will a little bit you're
probably the
cause of the common cold and uh you know
and possibly even
the kobet 19 i'm not sure at this point
because everything's been thrown at you
including now undoubtedly your alma
mater doesn't like you anymore
where we come the chairman said
something earlier today that really made
me think he said why all the drama
that's the most ironic statement coming
from this committee in the last 18
months that i've ever
heard of the drama that we're bringing
up today
we're we're seeming to just contort
ourselves to get to
uh some way to show that you have
nefarious motive i believe
uh like some of my side here i believe
the biggest problem you have
is telling the truth i believe that's
the problem that they have with you
you'll tell the truth
and you'll take responsibility for your
actions and i think that's why you're
being attacked
but i want to continue just on this
quote peaceful protest for a second you
made a comment just a second ago
talking about the courthouses just down
the street what if they decided do you
think that this
body right here would rise up if they
decided to go tonight and paint the
capitol building this party i'm not sure
i think this side would i'm not sure oh
yeah this other side i'm not sure
maybe the peaceful protest to burn down
the capitol maybe we're back to 1812
again
but also the other question i have is
and you've heard it earlier today the
stormtrooper comments by the speaker of
the house
and we know that that is a direct uh
reference to the paramilitary wing of
the nazi party
stormtroopers going at it do you believe
that that actually puts our law
enforcement community at a whole as a
son of a state trooper
i want to know your opinion don't you
think it encourages the violence that
we're seeing and encourages the
participation
against the police i think that's
possible and i think it's irresponsible
to call
these federal law enforcement officers
stormtroopers
yeah uh and we're seeing that thing
played out over and over let's switch
back to something else though that is
is i think more people here we've talked
about the investigations and
uh especially going with flynn do you
believe that there was actually a basis
to go after
general flynn i mean what we've seen so
far what's been released and especially
keeping a
an investigation open peter strzok kept
it open do you believe there's actually
a basis for the beginning of this
investigation
to start with or continuing it well i
would just say
i i asked another u.s attorney in saint
louis who had 10 years in the fbi and 10
years in the department of justice
as a career prosecutor to take a look at
it and and he determined based on
documents that had not been provided to
flynn's side and not been provided to
the court
that in fact there was no basis to
investigate
flynn and furthermore it was clearly
established by the documents that the
fbi agents who interviewed him did not
believe
that he thought he was lying well
there's another part of this as well
that concerns
uh what has been you know given to the
courts and in the interviews and that is
that
the facts were not disclosed to flynn
prior to the interview
that seems like a brady violation to me
do you believe that that was there's a
brady violation there in this case
no there wasn't a brady violation there
but i think what the
council concluded was that the only
purpose of the interview the only
purpose
was to try to catch them and and saying
something that they could then say was a
lie so it was an entrepreneur therefore
and therefore there was not a legit the
the interview was untethered to any
legitimate
uh investigation so as the law
enforcement officer in this country it
is your responsibility to provide
justice for both sides
not you know and just call it as it
should be and i think that's what you've
done there
uh continuing on durham case and i know
we're not talking specifically about the
durham investigation which we're hopeful
of
but to your knowledge and we're seeing
some release documents on the last
week or two that have said to your
knowledge has kevin klein smith or
anyone else at fbi or doj attempted
who was previously there attempted to
redeem themselves by cooperating with
the
investigation it's been slow and i can't
get into that okay
i understand that i have another issue
as we finish up
in looking at this between the rhetoric
between the investigation i think durham
investigation is something most of us
are waited for because we can't seem to
get this committee to actually believe
that the ig's report is worth adding
something
about this committee and there's not a
democrat or republican inside that can
make a legitimate claim
why the inspector general has not been
called before this committee to actually
explain his report except politics and
that's what this committee has become
all along
but i have another problem and i've
talked to you i've written to you about
this um and that's down with a district
attorney down in fulton county georgia
actually charging uh making felony
murder charges
on an officer and the interesting part
about this is what we do as
is as prosecutors do but the were you
aware that the district attorney failed
to seek an indictment from a grand jury
or even waited for a gbi investigation
to finish before bringing those charges
were you aware of that yes it was okay
as an attorney and again looking at this
with the environment we have right now
with police officers constantly under
attack from
from this committee and from others and
all over the country and especially from
the speaker of the house
as an attorney and especially a
prosecutor do you think it's appropriate
to charge a law enforcement officer with
a crime as severe as felony murder
without giving the investigation more
than a mere days and without obtaining
an indictment from the grand jury
and while you announce the charges lay
out a case that is full of falsehoods
i've said that i i would have preferred
and
that he had used the grand jury and had
waited until the georgia bureau had
completed its investigation i appreciate
your helping adam with that i yield
thank you with that the chair recognizes
uh mr johnson from georgia
thank you uh general for your opening
statement reads like it was written by
alex jones or roger stone
did you stand by that statement yes
now i'm sure that we can agree on some
things we disagree on a whole lot but
i'm sure we can agree on the fact that
president trump is just a prolific
tweeter isn't that correct he seems to
be
and he tweeted many times about the
roger stone
sentencing didn't he i don't know how
many times he tweeted about it well many
times you
and you are aware of them because you
said it would it's
hurts you from doing your job and isn't
it true that when prosecutors in the
roger stone case
filed a memo with the court recommending
a sentence of seven to nine
years in prison a few hours later
president trump tweeted that the
sentence recommendation was quote
a disgrace you're aware of that yes
and general barr several hours after
that
you filed the pleading with the court
stating that the sentence recommendation
would be changed and that you would be
asking for a lighter sentence for
roger stone isn't that correct no but no
what is correct
is that what is corrected on february
10th
monday i gave instructions as to what
time yeah i'm answering your question so
you gotta let him answer reclaiming my
time
you filed a sentencing recommendation
hours after president trump tweeted his
dissatisfaction with the stone
recommendation
you changed that recommendation the
night before
the night before that is monday night i
know your story but i'm asking well
i'm telling my story that's what i'm
here to do well i do
that's why i'm here well i'm here to
tell my story
and on the night before the night before
on february 10th
on february 10th reclaiming my time sir
reclaiming my time and i know you don't
want to answer
but the facts are clear sentencing
recommendation made in the morning
tweet in the afternoon you changed the
sentencing recommendation that
tweet was not in the afternoon the tweet
was made at i think 1 30 or 2 in the
morning well the
tweet was made before and after tweet
tweeted about that relentlessly and
you've agreed to that now when you filed
your
sentencing recommendation asking for a
lower
sentence i didn't ask for a lower sense
well you said that you were going to
recommend a lower sentence
and you said no i left it wasn't the
sentence that was recommended by the
line
prosecutors according to the sentencing
guideline
calculations it was within it was within
the guidelines but it was not within
justice department policy in my view
general boy you're expecting the
american people to believe
that you did not do what trump wanted
you to do
when you changed that sentencing
recommendation and lowered it for roger
stone
you think the american people don't
understand that you were carrying out
trumps
i was not i i had not discussed my
sentencing recommendation with anyone at
the white house or anyone
president exactly or anyone that's
outside you to do
and that's what you did no attorney
let me ask you do you think it's fair do
you think it is fair
for a year old man to be sent to
prison for seven to nine years it was in
accordance with the sentencing
no it was not you just said that it was
and your line prosecutors will testify
that it was also now i'm gonna move on
from that
the department your time as attorney it
is not the department herbert walker
bush you never changed the sentencing
recommendation
for a friend of uh herbert walker bush
did you
no i as i recall all right
no and over the course of your time as
trump
nothing was never elevated to me over
the course of your
tenure with trump you've changed two
sentencing recommendations not one but
two
correct which were that yeah michael
flynn
i didn't change it well you
said well you indicated that um
you yeah you changed it because the
original flynn
sentencing recommendation was for flynn
to serve zero to six months
but under your authority the justice
department
supplemented that recommendation with a
pleading that stated the department of
justice's
agreement with flynn's lawyers that
probation would be a reasonable sentence
and that the doj would not be sinking
prison time for michael friend
isn't that correct i don't think that's
what it said well that's what it said
sir you go back and read it
i i think both i think both pleadings
said that reclaiming my time
prior to you because gentlemen fixed
fire madam chair
you can you can give a speech or you can
ask questions if you do the latter you
need to let the witness answer the
questions
that's the chair's obligation chairs
responsibility allow that to happen
mr buck is recognized for five minutes
appearing before the committee today
general bar there is a disturbing
pattern
we have seen throughout history with
totalitarian systems of government
the leaders first seek to disarm the
population
then they encourage goon squads to
suppress opposing voices
and finally once they have disarmed and
silenced the opposition these
authoritarian leaders institute policies
that root out and crush
freedom in every form unfortunately the
american left has been infected with the
same totalitarian desire to remove
firearms and silence opposing views
as part of a campaign to achieve its
political ends
we've seen the scenario play out in
every major democrat-run city in america
progressive leaders pushed to disarm
law-abiding americans to further their
influence
while watching his crime rates soar we
even saw failed presidential and senate
candidate beto o'rourke proudly tell
americans
hell yes we're going to take your ar-15
and your ar or your ak-47
now the american left is actively
cheering as this fascist militia antifa
rages in the streets antifa is a
domestic terrorist organization that
hijacks peaceful rallies
organizes armed riots attacks peaceful
protesters burns buildings loots stores
and spreads hate reports of
antifa-linked attacks began
circulating in 2017. these thugs often
armed with sticks and pepper spray and
other uh other
instruments showed up to silence college
republican groups at berkeley
the left was silent then in june 2019
antifa jumped into the national
conversation after journalist andy noe
was brutally attacked in portland no
arrests were made
the left again was silent almost exactly
one year ago today the wall street
journal ran an op-ed stating portland
has to do something to deter political
violence or the city will get more of it
of course the city's feckless leadership
has only further encouraged antifa's
violent annex
as a result we've seen 61 straight
nights of violence in portland
antifa's fascist totalitarian activities
are now
oozing into other democrat-run cities
last sunday antifa launched a violent
assault on a peaceful
pro-police demonstration in denver
colorado
conservative leaders in colorado
including randy corpora a denver area
lawyer and radio talk show host
organized a family-friendly event in
honor of law enforcement appreciation
day
the atmosphere was peaceful and
accounted protesters were given plenty
of space to advocate their message
but as the afternoon wore on a swarm of
violent antifa thugs
infiltrated peaceful black lives matter
counter protesters
and began assaulting pro-police
americans
these are 20 and 30 year old thugs
assaulting 50
60 70 and even 80 year old americans who
only wanted to show their support for
law enforcement
what's worse denver's cowardly liberal
leadership ordered police to retreat
once they saw members of antifa entering
the fray
a denver police detective nick rogers
apologized for this terrible decision
detective rogers summed it up best in
the recent radio interview
quote i'm sorry on behalf of the rank
and file that's not
us that's not who we are it just kills
me
that we let good people down he
continued i found out that a retreat
order was given by the incident
commander
and we had one lieutenant step up and
say we aren't leaving
this lieutenant said these people are
going to get killed if we don't stay
so he kept his people there that's the
reason this thing didn't get
worse end of quote these are sad times
in america
free speech and the right to keep and
bear arms are both being threatened
by violent anarchists and the best our
chairman can do
is call antifa a myth
general barr this has to stop we can't
let antifa continue
terrorizing our country can you please
tell us about the appropriate use
of civil and criminal rico statutes to
address
violent criminal groups like antifa
in the uh in the wake of the the
beginning of these riots
um i asked our joint terrorism task
forces the fbi's joint terrorism task
forces around the country
uh to uh be our principal
means of developing evidence
and prosecuting uh violent extremist
terrorists who are involved in these
activities and one of the tools
obviously we would use is rico which can
be used against an organization
but that doesn't mean that we currently
have a ricoh case
uh pending okay i i thank the
gentleman and do you have anything you
want to say in response to
the speeches that have been given by the
other side and then you've been cut off
yeah well what's on lafayette on
lafayette the gentleman's time is
expired
guys for a brief recess
yeah madam chair the witness like him
mrs carr mr bart that's really
ten minutes
the committee will stand in recess for
five minutes
the committee's in recess sir
like oh temperatures
that's the biggest thing
nothing to say that's it
no it's been okay as long as you keep it
if you start tilting it the wind will
catch it
i have not evidently i think they went
in if you go in
with the through the rotunda you can go
in the rotunda and come out that door
evidently
the committee is in session the chair
recognizes mr deutch for five minutes
uh thank you madam chair uh attorney
general barr
you just told us that nothing was ever
elevated to me you had said
in an interview recently that there's a
process in place an escalation
system it's the ag's responsibility to
resolve it how is this elevated to you
the case of roger stone
on monday february 10 the u.s attorney
was with me and he raised the issue with
me so it was elevated by timothy
and um had it been elevated
uh during the two months between the
time the conviction came in
under the former us attorney and uh
and the time that timothy shea started i
i think
shane may have had conversations with
people did you ever have conversations
with a former us attorney about this
case
about the sentencing i i don't recall
any discussion about stone
right so timothy shea you said in the
interview that he was new he had just
started
um he's he was new but he worked for you
for a long time didn't he
yes was his job for you well when i was
attorney general 30 years ago he worked
no no no just
just now he was he was on my staff he
advised you on
on criminal justice policy in law
enforcement right correct
and you act you named him acting u.s
attorney
had you discussed the stone case with
him before you named him acting u.s
attorney
no did you just go sentencing with him
not before the first time was when he
came in it wasn't monday actually
just to refresh your recollection in a
prior interview you said he came in
the week before he came in to see some
senior staff
that's right no that's what i said he
may have he may have had discussions
with people in the deputy's office i was
not involved in those discussions
basically i didn't as far as i can
provide no substantive involvement in
stone until that monday
when he came in in the morning well the
i'm sorry mr attorney general the week
before when he came in to see the
the senior staff that he had worked with
the week before when he was working
i know i said i said i think he had
raised it with people in the deputy's
office that's senior staff
too right i understand but i was not
involved he started on he started on
july 31st the first week he was there he
came to raise this issue
i think he started february first right
the first week he was there he came into
your office to raise the issue of
sentencing
um in the interview you did with abc he
said no i don't think he
came that's what you that's what you
told abc news you said that he's talked
to senior staff not you perhaps but he
talked to senior staff
that i don't know you know i think i
speak english i said that before he came
in to see
me i believe he had some conversation
conversation with the senior staff
right that's right before you see it
we're saying the same thing but the
first
it was raised with me was on monday did
you talk to the senior staff after they
spoke with him
i think at a nine o'clock meeting uh
they said that uh he was trying to work
something out on sentencing and he was
actually optimistic that something could
be worked
out so i didn't think of it as an issue
until that monday
when he told me that right so then
prosecutors so then he fi
so then they filed he filed the
sentencing memo and the sentencing memo
called for seven to nine years it's the
policy of the us attorney's office to
suggest a specific guideline range which
um which they did and then you overrule
the line prosecutors they asked for a
lower sentence
and you gave some reasons you talked
about health health is to be considered
only for an extraordinary physical
impairment did that apply to roger stone
mr attorney general that's what the
guidelines said that's well actually i i
can't
you know i can't reveal all the
information i'm not asking what his
health was but did that apply
no okay and did what and so he said what
apply
his health health is a reason
i know is that is that the reason for
roger stone
or you're asking for a lower sentence
let me go on it says
let me go on hold on a second age can be
consideration
it says only if it creates conditions
that are of an unusual degree
and distinguish the case from typical
cases he was 67 today judge agreed with
me
congressman no that's not just i'm not
asking you that the judge agreed i'm not
asking whether i know you're not i'm not
asking you that and the issue here is
the issue here is whether roger stone
was treated differently because he was
friends with the president
when you asked that when you asked to
reduce the sentence you said
enhancements were
technically applicable mr attorney
general can you think of
any other cases where the defendant
threatened
to kill a witness threatened to threaten
the judge
lied to a judge where the department of
justice claimed that those were mere
technicalities can you think of even one
the judge agreed with rng
and you think of even one i'm not asking
about the judge i'm asking about what
you did
to reduce the sentence of of roger stone
yes can you think mr attorney general he
threatened
the life of a witness and the witness
and you just do that as a technicality
mr attorney general
is there another time i answer the
question can i have just a few seconds
to answer that i'm asking if there's
another time in this case just
a judgment the judge agreed with our
answer my question is
it's unfortunate and it the appearance
is that as you said earlier
this is exactly what you want the
essence of rule of law is that we have
one rule for everybody
and we don't in this case because he's a
friend of the president i yield back
back mr uh
mr attorney general thank you so much
for being here with us
today um i'm a member of both this
committee
as well as the appropriations committee
and i've been able to see
firsthand um both the funding and the
operation of the department
additionally before i was elected to
congress
i served on the city council in my
hometown of montgomery
alabama and i have witnessed the
importance
and the value of various justice
department grant programs
in the resources to state and local
governments
for example the alabama fusion center
which is designed to combine information
between federal state
and local government private sector
entities and the intelligence community
has been a recipient of these federal
grants
and the alabama fusion center is also
responsible for the
alabama center for missing and exploited
children
and has done a great job in work
in combating child exploitation
do you believe that congress is
adequately funding programs that provide
state and local agencies with the tools
that they need
to be effective in preventing and
pursuing crimes such as
child exploitation and human trafficking
particularly over the internet
i think we could always use more
resources for that congressman but but
if i could just have a moment of your
time to respond to these questions here
on
uh that were being asked about this the
roger stone sentencing
the uh u.s
attorney came to me and said that the
four aligned prosecutors were
threatening to resign unless they could
recommend
seven to nine years but there was no
comparable case to support that
it would have been very disparate
sentence all the cases were clustered
around
three years sentence for that and the
way they had gotten to the
seven to nine was by applying an
enhancement
and there and there are debates all the
time within the department of justice
about the proper calculations under the
guidelines and whether a particular
enhancement applies or doesn't apply
and those are usually worked out and
solved
but here they were saying that they were
taking an enhancement that has
traditionally been applied to mafioso
and things like that threatening a
witness and they were applying it to him
because he had a
phone call at night where he told the
witness that if you want to get it on
let's get it on and i'll take your dog
and we felt that technically could apply
but in this case
it really didn't reflect the underlying
conduct and the overarching
requirement at the department of justice
is that we do not presume and
automatically apply the guidelines we
make
individual assessments of the defendant
and what is really just under the case
and nothing
that is excessive and
these individuals were trying to force
the u.s
attorney who was new in the office to
adopt seven to nine and i made the
decision
no uh we are going to uh leave it up to
the judge
and that later when that was not done
that evening i told people we had to go
back and correct that the next morning
so that that's the sequence of events
but at the end of the day
the proof of the pudding is in the uh in
the eating the judge
said she would not have gone along she
didn't think with the first
recommendation
because the enhancement artificially
inflated
the exposure of the defendant and she
came out exactly where
i had come out so at the end of the day
the question is fairness to the
individual
and even though i was going to get a lot
of criticism
at the end of the up for for doing that
uh i think at the end of the day my
obligation is to be fair to the
individual thank you for
permitting me i'm happy to to have
yielded you uh
time to respond uh that being said uh mr
attorney general
um as i am a departing member of
congress and have just
a few short moments left i just want to
express to you
uh in the department how important this
issue that i originally asked you about
is to me both as a member of congress
representing my constituents in alabama
but also as a mother of two beautiful
children
and i am increasingly alarmed um
about the way that children are just one
click away
from um being on a website a forum
or a chat room or a social media site
while
where bad actors uh may be lurking and
whereas i only have
a few short seconds left i would just
ask you
in the time that i have left in congress
that we could continue to work together
to combat child exploitation
and human trafficking and i appreciate
all the work that you're doing on this
absolutely congresswoman and as you know
one of the
most difficult issues coming up is uh
encryption because as this material gets
encrypted in the chat rooms
and the areas where they groom these
young children
once it becomes encrypted it'll be very
hard for us to police it
right thank you so much i yield back
thank you the gentlelady yields back
from his best
attorney general barr when it comes to
police engagement last august when
speaking to the national fraternal order
of police
you shared your views on police
engagement with the public you stated
and i quote
underscore the need to comply first and
if warranted complain later
this will make everyone safe the police
subject the police
suspects and the community at large and
those who resist must be prosecuted
i repeat zero tolerance for resisting
police this will save lives do you stand
by that statement
yes i think it's very important zero
tolerance attitude is costing lives not
saving them especially in communities
well i'm not saying i reclaim my time a
movement and protests have arisen in
response to police brutality
here are a few examples of who bears the
cost of zero tolerance
elijah mcclain was walking home from a
convenience store
when he was approached by police he had
not committed a crime police held him in
a choke hold
for 15 minutes then injected him with
catamine
ketamine not under a doctor's
supervision but at the direction of
non-medically trained and
unlicensed police officers are you
familiar with that case
no do you know how frequently ketamine
is used by law enforcement to subdue
civilians especially people of color no
did you know if police departments have
been documented as directing paramedics
and emts to eject
ketamine during arrests no um
have you well then i guess you haven't
evaluated the use of force
tactics by because since becoming a.g
and especially this particular tactic of
sedu
subduing suspects with ketamine not with
respect academy
will you commit to directing the
department to evaluate the protocols
around the use of ketamine choke holds
and other methods used by federal law
enforcement officials
when making arrests or detaining
subjects well absolutely under the
president's executive order we are
reviewing uh
thank you anderson of force and working
with police departments
especially the ketamine that's pretty
outrageous
george floyd was killed by a police
officer via chokehold for eight minutes
and 46 seconds
a police officer knelt on his neck as he
as he begged for his life
he was suspected of using a counterfeit
twenty dollar bill
that's how zero tolerance can amount to
a death sentence for black men
when used in communities of color with
george floyd screaming as we all know he
couldn't breathe
now consider james holmes who murdered
12 people
and injured 70 others in a movie theater
in aurora colorado
the same town as elijah mclean where he
was arrested
james wore body armor had a knife
semi-automatic weapons and an ar-15
yet he was calmly arrested by the same
police department as elijah mclean
without a chokehold art injection of
dylan roof used a gun to murder nine
people and injured another
at emmanuel african methodist episcopal
church in south carolina
when he was arrested no choke holds no
injections
he was treated so well that officers
brought dylan roof burger king
after arresting him are you familiar
with that case yes
i raised those two examples to follow up
on what my colleague from texas
highlighted earlier
that the department is not doing enough
to address issues of racism bias
and brutality in law enforcement when
someone who commits
mass murder is calmly arrested and
served burger king
while a young man walking down the
street is placed in a chokehold
and injected with ketamine then dies
uh you said that under the executive
order the administration is looking
at chokeholds what have you uh
determined so far
well we're uh setting up a system
uh of certification of police
departments and part of what our charter
is
is to come up with criteria that will be
used for certification including
limitations on use of force
specifically including chokeholds so in
the george floyd justice and policing
act
part of it called for a national
registry of law enforcement officers
as a resource for police chiefs to
determine who are the best candidates
for jobs
as you may or may not be aware tamir
rice might be alive today if police
if the police chief who hired him had
known that that police officer
had been fired from another department
what is your
view of a national registry of law
enforcement officers
uh the second aspect of the president's
executive order is to set up a database
like that so that all uh determinations
of excessive force around the country
go into that database and if police
departments aren't reporting that
information they wouldn't be certified
so we do believe in one national point
where you can go in
and get uh determinations of excessive
force on
uh law enforcement candidates for jobs
good thank you and
and i do want to uh comment on part of
your opening statement when you were
saying that after the jim crow period
that our justice system was equal and um
i don't believe that that's the laws
i said the laws were made the laws are
made equal they are certainly not
applied equally
we do have systemic problems in our
law enforcement system our criminal
justice system on every
level the fact of the matter is 2.3
million people in the united states are
incarcerated we incarcerate 24 percent
of the world's prisoners
34 are black while african-americans are
just 13
of the of the u.s population so justice
is still
not equal nor are our laws and i think
when we look at
how many people are incarcerated or how
many people are killed
it is not the numbers it is the
percentage to the percentage
of that group in the u.s population
i yield back my time gentlelady
gentlelady yields back
mr gates thank you mr chairman mr
attorney general you've described the
prosecution of roger stone as righteous
that's clearly something that the
president and i disagree with you on
i would suggest that perhaps the
prosecution of andrew mccabe
who lied four times thrice under the
penalty of perjury
would be more righteous i would suggest
to you that
uncovering the criminal conspiracy that
existed where
people in our own government were trying
to convince intelligence agents and
operatives around the world
to destabilize our elections and to
discredit our president
would perhaps be more righteous but as
we said here today i don't think that
mr stone or mr mccabe or any of those
other folks are
killing anyone or burning down our
buildings and so
i'd like to focus our effort on the most
acute need i believe our country has
you've recently said that you believe
antifa to be a terrorist
organization what's your basis for that
belief
i i'm not sure i said terrorist
organization i said we're investigating
it as domestic terrorism but
antifa there are a number of violent
extreme groups in the united states and
they're across
the spectrum antifa is heavily
represented in the recent riots that's
not to say they're the only group
involved and
they have been identified as involved in
a number of the
violent mob actions that have taken
place around the country
mr attorney general i i saw the chairman
of the judiciary committee recently say
that
antifa is a myth that their involvement
in this violence
isn't something that that is real what's
your reaction to the chairman
i don't think it's a myth uh antifa is
is
is uh uh can be best thought of i think
as a as a umbrella term for
what is essentially a movement comprised
of
uh loosely organized groups around the
country and some of these
in some areas of the country there are a
number of groups and there are sort of
centers of activity
the groups as i say are loosely
organized but they
are definitely organized uh but as
since they have an anarchic temperament
they don't get along very well with each
other so i'm not suggesting it's a
national
organization that that moves nationally
they tend to to get organized for an
event
and there's a lot of
organization right before an event
occurs
but we see a lot of the organization
during the mob
violence and and that is a really
important distinction when determining
how to apply
particularly our rico laws to an
organization like this
if antifa is merely something that
inspires people to go out and commit
violence that strikes me as legally
distinct from antifa being
an organizing influence to assist people
in committing crimes one question i get
from my constituents is they watch the
death and violence and disruption and
chaos
in seattle and in portland and in other
places is whether or not
there's a risk that that could
metastasize to other areas of the
country
have you given consideration to the risk
that might
befall other american communities if the
department of justice were not to take
action
to protect and preserve federal property
in places like portland
yes absolutely you know we are concerned
about this problem metastasizing around
the country
and and so uh we feel that we have to uh
in a place like portland where even
where we don't have the support of the
uh
the state the local government uh
we have to take a stand and defend this
federal property we can't
get to a level where we're going to
accept these kinds of violent attacks on
federal courts
and if you did what my democrat
colleagues were asking
if you merely abandoned that federal
property allowed it to be overrun
allow the people inside to be harmed is
it your view then that
antifa and other violent people engaged
in these acts
would simply stop would simply accept
that as their sole victory
or is it your expert opinion having
dealt with a number of law enforcement
and criminal cases
in your legal career that that they
wouldn't stop that they would go to the
next town to the next community and
potentially inspire more violence
there's no doubt in my mind that it
would spread
and what comfort can you give americans
in my district and around the country
that that you will stop this that you
will stop the burning and destruction of
federal property
and that you will that you will give
confidence to regular americans that
they can go out in the streets
without the risk of this terrorism well
as you can see in in portland we have
a relatively small number of federal
officers who have been withstanding this
for almost two months
it's a great strain but we cannot just
stand aside and allow the federal court
to be destroyed
thank you for your service and for your
great work i yield back gentleman yields
back mr richmond
thank you mr chairman attorney general
you
started your testimony with eloquent
words about the life and legacy of
john lewis fighting systematic racism
voter intimidation civil rights the one
thing that you have
in common with your two predecessors
both attorney general sessions
and attorney general whitaker is that
when you all came here
and brought your top staff you brought
no black people
that cert is systematic racism that is
exactly what john lewis
spent his life uh fighting and so i
would just suggest
uh that actions speak louder than words
and
you should really should keep the name
of the honorable john lewis
out of the department of justice's mouth
let me also say you mentioned bogus
russiagate
in your opinion as the attorney general
of the united states of america
did russia interfere or attempt to
interfere in the 2016 election
uh yes in your position as the attorney
general of the united states is russia
attempting to interfere in the
2020 presidential election uh
i think i think we have to assume that
they are
thank you sir uh now
let's talk about the integrity of the
election which is also
uh something congressman lewis uh fought
for
jared kushner implied that the president
could move the election day
can a sitting u.s president move in
election day
actually i haven't looked into that
question under the constitution
well 2 u.s code section 7 says federal
election date
is the tuesday after the first monday in
november
so if you take that as a correct statute
is there any executive action by a
president i've never been asked the
question before i've never looked into
it
as attorney general of the united states
do you believe
that this 2020 presidential election
will be rigged
i have no reason to think it will be uh
president
trump tweeted uh that the election will
be
rigged but he also tweeted that when he
was losing to
hillary clinton and he tweeted that the
day after
it was fox showed that he was losing to
trump
but i don't want to be too political do
you believe as the attorney general of
the united states
that mail-in voting will lead to massive
voter fraud
i think there's a high risk that it will
do you ever
vote by mail-in ballot apparently i did
once at least
but you believe that other people voting
by mail could lead to massive fraud well
what i've talked about
made very clear is that i'm not talking
about accommodations to people who have
to be out of the state
or have some particular need not to uh
inability to go and vote what i'm
talking about is the wholesale
conversion of election to
unfolding you do understand that african
americans disproportionately do not
survive
covet 19 coronavirus you are aware of
that i didn't hear the question
you are aware that african americans
black people disproportionately die
from covet 19 coronavirus correct
yes i think that's right and not that it
would be
uh the first time that african americans
would risk their lives
to vote in this country to preserve its
democracy
but the suggestion is that
them having the ability to vote by mail
would somehow
lead to massive voter fraud but i won't
stick to that no
i didn't say that i just state i think
what is a reality which is that if you
have wholesale mail in
voting it substantially increases the
risk of fraud
but it doesn't make it lightweight now i
also saw on
tv that the president said he's not sure
that he'll accept the election results
can a president just protest because he
lost an election
protesting what says well can he contest
an election
just because he simply loses gore versus
you know bush b gore well i think that
that was over uh
a slim voter margin i'm talking about if
it is very clear
that the president has lost an election
uh does he have a remedy to contest
the election not that i'm aware of uh
let me go back to what uh representative
bass mentioned
you mentioned the number that there were
eight african-americans killed by the
police and eleven
uh white people killed by the police if
you use those numbers
of that 85 of that population is white
15
of that population is black but if you
actually look at the deaths according to
the numbers you just gave
42 of the deaths are african-american
and 58 are white that is a
glaring disparity in terms of population
and i just give you those numbers well
not not necessarily because i will
adjust it by
no i i just did that for you i'm using
your numbers and according to your
numbers
african americans are four or five times
more likely
uh than their percentage of the
population to be killed by police than
their wife
i just wanted to give you that based on
your numbers
actually the studies i've seen have
suggested two things one
that in fact police
are less likely to
shoot at a black suspect a little bit
more likely to shoot at white
however that black that police are are
more inclined to use non-lethal force in
a
contact with an african-american suspect
so those are the those in terms of the
statistics that's what it looks like to
me
any data that you have that shows that
african americans are less likely to die
at the hands of police or be shot
or shot at uh to me is
a incorrect uh
analysis but i am interested in seeing
it so if you have it
please see it i won't call it any names
but if that data exists
i would be more than happy to see it and
since you're sending me that data can
you send me the data of african
americans within the department of
justice
how many you have in leadership ranks
all the way down thank you and i yield
back
the gentleman yields back i would remind
mr jordan mr biggs and mr johnson
to stop violating the rules of the
committee to stop
violating the safety of the members of
the committee to stop
um holding themselves out as not caring
by refusing to wear their masks is it
permissible to drink
not permissible not to drink we can't
drink
[Music]
he went and that's why i took off my
mess mr chairman
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go okay mr jordan
is recognized
mr attorney let's clear up a few things
judge berman jackson agreed with your
uh with your stone sentencing
recommendation is that right
that's right yeah she said i am
concerned seven to nine years would be
greater than necessary i agree with the
defense and with the government's second
memorandum so it couldn't be more clear
they agreed with you lafayette square
would saint john's church be standing
today
if you had not taken action well i think
uh that was on sunday that was on sunday
night and i think
law enforcement did use tear gas and my
understanding is that night to clear the
way so that the fire trucks could get
into
to uh save saint john's church the
church
that was on sunday night though
understand understand the time frame but
it would
would it be standing today if there had
not been action taken by federal law
enforcement and local law enforcement
right 38 people unmasked michael flynn's
name
49 times in a two-month time frame seven
people at the treasury department
unmasked michael flynn's name
is this an issue that mr durham is
looking into
i've asked another u.s attorney to look
into the issue of unmasking because of
you know the high number of unmaskings
and some that do not
readily appear to have been um in the
line of normal
business wait a minute i want to be
clear so there is a there is another
investigation on that issue specifically
going on at the justice department right
now
yes wow that's great
so mr durham is looking at how the whole
trump russia thing started you have
another u.s attorney can you give us
that u.s attorney's name or is that
something you're comfortable doing
john bash of texas john bash of texas is
looking specifically at the fact
that unmasking 38 people 49 times
unmasked michael flynn's name and
probably other unmaskings that took
place in the final days of the obama
biden administration is that accurate
actually a much longer period of time
even before that yes
thank you mr i appreciate that that's
information that the committee did not
uh did not know
are peaceful protests violent mr
attorney general
no do peaceful protests destroy
businesses
no the peace will protest injure
officers no
do peaceful protests attack civilians no
do peaceful protests
burn down buildings no that was
you know the video we played it's hard
to watch it's really hard to watch to
see that happening in our great country
but there was what one the start of it
was almost laughable where you have the
reporter saying
as the building is burning behind him
it's not generally speaking an unruly
protest
it's mostly just a protest i mean it's
almost laughable when you have the
reporters saying
i guess i guess he's saying it's not a
fire it's just a burning building
i guess he's saying it's a peaceful
burning building
um a few weeks ago
well let me ask you this i want to go
right to this
is defunding the police a rational
policy
no i think if anything i'm more
concerned that the the police be
adequately funded today
and and get more resources a lot of the
things we need to do to address
uh some of the concerns people have
about what they saw in minneapolis are
going to take some resources some of the
training
that we have to do and uh one of the
difficulties in our country
it's not a difficulty it's a fact we
have 18 000 law enforcement agencies
some
most of them are very very small and so
we have to find a way of training
uh you know making sure the training is
pushed out is it dangerous
dangerous to defund the police extremely
dangerous extremely dangerous and some
of the ordinances you're seeing cities
pass are also dangerous
you familiar with the letter that chief
of police of seattle carmen best
sent to business owners and residents in
that city
yes i am saying that you know she cannot
protect
uh she can't do her job her police force
cannot do the job because
exactly what she said gives officers the
policy they're trying to pass that
goodness of court stopped it the policy
they're trying to pass gives officers
no ability and she emphasized no not us
not not you mr train not me
gives officers no ability to safely
intercede to preserve property in the
midst of large violent
crowds she also said in that letter
again she's taken the leadership and
responsibility to tell the business
owners
the citizens that she's supposed to
serve
she also tells me that letter i've done
my due diligence on informing the
council numerous times so she's saying i
tried to tell him
these these people won't listen to me
and then finally she says this and this
is the scary part this is why it's so
dangerous
she says this in her letter seattle
police will have an adjusted deployment
that's a nice way of saying you're on
your own
we can't help you that is how scary this
defund the police
and here's the kicker here's the kicker
these same cities sent you a letter last
week the same week
chief of police best does this to the
residents and citizens of
of her city her mayor sends you a letter
blaming you
blaming the federal government for the
violence that is happening in these
cities
that that is how ridiculous the left's
position has become
i appreciate the work you do mr attorney
general i'm over time i yield back thank
you
gentlemen yields mr jeffries uh mr barr
the job of the attorney general is to
defend
the best interests of the people and
serve as the people's
lawyer but during your time as attorney
general you have consistently
undermined democracy undermine the
constitution
and undermine the health safety and
well-being of the american people
all to personally benefit
donald trump now you just testified
that there's no mechanism for a
president to
contest an election that has clearly
been won
by the opponent mr attorney general
what will you do if donald trump loses
the election
on november 3rd but refuses to leave
office on january 20th
well if the results are clear i would
leave office
do you believe that there is any basis
or legitimacy to donald trump's recent
claim
that he can't provide an answer as to
whether he would leave
office i really i'm not familiar with
these comments or the context in which
they occurred so i'm not going to give
commentary on them okay thank you he
just stated that publicly about a week
ago to fox
news mr barr during a radio interview
this spring with hugh hewitt you praise
president trump's coronavirus response
as superb correct
who did you did okay over 150
000 americans have died
more than 4 million americans have been
infected more than 5 million americans
have lost
their health care over 100 000 small
businesses have permanently
closed more than 50 million americans
are out of work this is not the outcome
of superb
leadership what we've gotten from donald
trump is exactly
the opposite let's explore
i disagree with that that that was not a
question that was a statement let's
explore in february president trump
falsely claimed
that the number of coronavirus cases
would go from 15 to zero in a few days
was that superb
yes or no i i'd have to see the context
in which it was said
here's the context the number of cases
didn't go down to zero
it's over 4 million let's go to march
in that month president trump said i
take no responsibility at all
for the failure and testing was that
superb
yes or no it was accurate
the the problem with the testing system
was a function of president obama's
mishandling of the cdc and his efforts
to
centralize everything in the cdc thank
you thank you mr barr
that is inaccurate that's amazing it
wasn't until this afternoon
it wasn't claiming my time in april
president trump irresponsibly suggested
that the american people inject
themselves
with bleach was that superb
yes or no that's not what i heard that's
exactly what he said
that's what the american people heard
and you know it
and you can't defend it let's move on to
may
in that month on national nurses day
president trump falsely called ppe
shortages fake news while nurses and
other health care professionals
resorted to wearing trash bags
and ski goggles to protect themselves
fake news was that superb yes
or no i think the administration did a
good job of
of mustering ppe and and the
national supply of ppe was run down
during the obama administration and
never replaced
thank you mr barr the answer is no
it was not superb by june
president trump irresponsibly continued
to refuse to wear a
mask despite the public health guidance
from his own experts was that superb
yes or no which guidance the earlier
guidance that the masks wouldn't work
you know exactly the guidance that we're
talking about
the cdc and dr falchi in april
recommended that the american people
wear a mask but donald trump has become
the poster boy for the anti-massive move
donald donald trump has probably tested
more than any other human being on the
face yeah mr barr
the answer is the refusal to wear a mask
is not
superb last question in july president
trump
falsely claimed that 99 percent
of covet 19 cases are quote totally
harmless was that superb yes
or no i think essentially what he was
saying is that the
the fatality rate relatively is very low
very low
the answer is 150 000
americans are dead it has been a failure
of epic proportions in fact
donald trump's response to the
coronavirus pandemic has been the worst
failure
of any president in american history
and the american people have paid the
price
i yield back gentleman yields back who
seeks recognition
well i guess i do it's i think it's my
turn to speak
and ask questions is that correct mr
chairman
then i seek recognition sir
bless your heart thank you um
attorney general barr chairman nadler
opened up his statement by saying
you can no longer hide behind a legal
fiction
that that caused me some consternation i
had no idea what he was talking about do
you have any idea what he's talking
about
i don't recall that phrase and what
context well
who knows what context i mean he was
just kind of rattling on there but
he was he was uh attacking you and your
performance in virtually everything he
could and said you can no longer hide
behind a legal fiction
and i didn't see any connection with
anything else he had been saying so i
wondered if you had seen anything
apparently you didn't see anything
either
the next person to ask questions was the
gentlelady from california who
consistently referred to civilian
federal agents as federal troops
and intimating if you will that
portland was peaceable until federal
civilian agents arrived on the scene
essentially it's kind of analogous to
blaming a fire department for showing up
to put out a fire
and then being blamed for starting the
fire
attorney general barr let's just have it
on the record
was there violence and attempts to burn
down
vandalize the building and attack um
civilian employees of the federal
government prior to any other federal
agents or the reinforcements being sent
in of federal agents
yeah my recollection is our main effort
to reinforce was around the fourth of
july period and it had been going on for
quite a while before that
let's talk about lafayette square for a
second um the
uh leading up to june 1st you had
violent mobs disobeying the 11 pm curfew
they set fire to parked cars demolished
coffee shops and banks burned american
flags and even intentionally set fire to
st
john's episcopal church near lafayette
square
secret service and park police
appropriate use of safe
restorative force um actually
cleared that up in total however 51 u.s
park police officers were injured
during the weekend leading up to the
perimeter expansion can you
do you want to expand on right on the
actions regarding with that lafayette
part right so for the 29th 30th and 31st
there was unprecedented
rioting right around the white house
very violent during that time as you say
about 50 park police and a comparable
number is my recollection of secret
service
so we had about nine i think around 90
officers
injured i'm talking about things like
concussions uh one was operated on and
so forth
uh we had the president it was so bad
that as
it's been reported the secret service
recommended the president go down to the
shelter
we had a breach of the treasury
department
the historical building on on lafayette
park was burned down the lodge
saint john's was was set on fire
bricks were thrown at the police
repeatedly they took crowbars and
pried up the pavers at on lafayette park
and threw those at the police
balloons of caustic liquid were thrown
on the police
and it was clear when i arrived at the
white house on monday
there was total consensus that the we
couldn't allow that to happen
uh so close to the white house uh that
kind of rioting
and therefore we had to move the
perimeter out
one block and push it up toward i street
and
there was already a plan in being at
that point
that the park police and the secret
service had worked out the night
before which was to put the perimeter
further away and then give them time to
put a non-scalable fence across the
northern part
of the park during the day
during monday the the factors that led
to the timing of it were
that that movement was going to be made
as soon as there were enough
uh units in place to actually perform it
and
units were very slow in getting into
place throughout the day much to my
frustration because i wanted it moved
before there was a big buildup of
demonstrators
and also the fencing had to be delivered
and when those things were accomplished
the tactical uh commander in charge of
the park police
proceeded with the with the movement of
pushing the perimeter
so this was this was something conceived
of long before and didn't turn on the
nature of the crab although i would say
the crowd was very unruly and
and while the tactical considerations
were made by
the park police uh you know they they
tried to respond to the situation to say
that this had to do
with the photo on the bus you know i
don't mean to analogize this to a
military operation but it's akin to
saying that we invaded the philippines
in world war ii so douglas macarthur
could walk through the surf on the beach
one follows the other but we did not
invade the philippines so that dope
macarthur could
walk to the beach thank you
general yields back uh mr suawell mr
barr have you ever intervened other than
to help
the president's friend get a reduced
prison sentence for any other
case where a prosecutor had filed a
penalty recommendation with the court
a sentencing recommendation yeah have
you ever intervened other than that case
for the president's friend
not that i recall if you're does that
seem like something you'd recall where
you would well i'm saying i can't really
remember my first
if you let me finish the question i i
can't remember 30 years ago i was
attorney
as attorney general now uh but uh no i
didn't but that's because
issues come up to the attorney general
in a dispute and i've never heard of a
dispute i've never heard of a dispute in
the department
where line prosecutors threatened to
quit
there's two systems of justice one for
mr trump and his cronies
and another for the rest of us but that
can only happen if you enable it
at your confirmation hearing you were
asked do you believe
a president could lawfully issue a
pardon in exchange for the recipient's
promise to not incriminate him
you said no not to what that would be a
crime
you were asked could a president issue a
pardon in exchange for the recipient's
promise to not incriminate him
and you responded no that would be a
crime is that right yes i said that
you said a crime you didn't say you'd be
wrong you didn't say it be unlawful you
said
you'd be a crime and when you said that
that a president
swapping a pardon to silence the witness
would be a crime you were promising the
american people that if you saw that
you would do something about it is that
right that's right now mr barr are you
investigating donald trump for commuting
the prison sentence of his long-time
friend and political advisor roger stone
no why not
why should i well let's talk about that
mr stone was convicted by a jury
on seven counts of line in the russia
investigation he bragged that he lied to
save trump's butt
but why would he lie your prosecutors mr
barr told a jury
that stone lied because the truth looked
bad for donald trump
and what truth is that well donald trump
denied in written answers to the russia
investigators
that he talked to roger stone during the
time roger stone was in contact
with agents of a russian influence
operation
there's evidence that trump and stone
indeed did talk during that time
you would agree that it's a federal
crime to lie under oath is that right
yes it's a crime for you it's a crime
for me and it's certainly a crime for
the president of the united states is
that right
yes so if donald trump lied to the
mueller investigators
which you agree would be a crime then
roger stone was in a position to expose
donald trump's lies
are you familiar with the december 3rd
2018 tweet
where donald trump said roger stone had
shown guts
by not testifying against him no i'm not
familiar with that
you don't read the president's tweets no
well there's a lot of evidence in the
president's treats mr attorney general i
think you should start reading them
because he said
mr stones showed guts but on july 10
of this year roger stone declared to a
reporter
i had 29 or 30 conversations with trump
during the campaign period
trump knows i was under enormous
pressure to turn on him it would have
eased my situation considerably
but i didn't the prosecutors wanted me
to play judas
i refused are you familiar with that
stone statement
actually i'm not so how can you sit here
and tell us
why should i investigate the president
of the united states if you're not even
aware of the facts concerning the
president using the pardon or
commutation power
to swap the silence of a witness
because we we require you know a
reliable predicate before we open a
criminal investigation
and i just gave you something i don't
consider it i consider it a very rube
goldberg theory that you have well it
sounds like
you're hearing this and by the way
there's going to be a lot to be a lot
more people under investigation mr
attorney general the very same day that
roger stone said that donald trump
that's one of the no surprises the truth
the standards of justice were really
during the
tail end of the obamacare mr attorney
general let's
turn to the michael cohen case are you
aware
sir that michael cohen after being
released from prison was asked to not
engage with the media including
to write a book were you aware that that
was going to be asked of him was i aware
yes no do you know if anyone else in
your department was aware
uh maybe i should tell you what happened
why don't you tell us what happened
okay he was furloughed from the bureau
of prisons
no no why don't you tell us why he was
asked i will tell you because
something that people don't seem to
understand is that his home confinement
was not
being supervised by the bureau of
prisons it was being supervised
by the probation office which is part of
the u.s court system
and it was the u.s court system that had
the requirements about
that u.s court system called your
actions retaliatory
do you agree with that no so well i know
is what i
what has been said in court before the
judge and in the record
which is that the individual uh was then
called by the u.s court system
saying that this guy cohen is
uncooperative he's not agreeing to the
conditions
and at that point the bureau of prisons
person
made the decision that he was no longer
eligible for home conditions that a
federal judge said no other
inmate had ever been asked of in his
experience mr barr you told abc news
that the president's tweets
sometimes make your job impossible but
sir
your job is only impossible if you
enable the president's corrupt schemes
and i yield back
thank you mr chairman mr attorney
general the constitution says the
president shall have the power
to grant reprieves and pardons for
offenses against the united states
except in cases of impeachment
do you note any other limitations in the
constitution on the president's
power to pardon no has the president
exceeded that power
no my colleague from georgia mr johnson
implied that
in challenging the sentencing
recommendation of roger stone you were
doing the bidding of the president he he
didn't want to hear your response i i
would
well no i was a roger stone i never
discussed our sentencing
recommendation with anyone outside the
department of justice
it was a very condensed period of time i
first
heard i made the decision that we
shouldn't take a position
as to the precise sentence but should
leave it up to the judge
and we should not affirmatively advocate
for seven to nine years and i made that
uh on monday the 10th and that that
night
we filed the department file and it
didn't reflect what i had decided so
that night i told people we had to fix
it first thing in the morning
so we did as soon as i got in we
we went we went forward with a plan to
file
at that point i learned about the
president's tweet because i don't
monitor the president's tweets
uh and i hesitated because i knew
that i would be attacked for doing it uh
people would
make the you know argue that i did it
because of the tweet
but i felt at the end of the day i
really had to go forward
with our filing because it was the right
thing to do and i'm glad the judge
agreed with it we're learning more and
more about the targeting and prosecution
and extortion of michael flynn
bipartisan officials of the fbi
no one has been held accountable for
this grotesque abuse of power
knowing that agents with a political
agenda can take
anything that someone says edit it
misrepresent it
prosecute it and then extort confessions
by
threatening family members and to do so
with impunity why would anyone in his
right mind ever want to talk to an fbi
agent again
well i i don't you know i haven't
reached judgments and i'm not suggesting
that all those facts he's set forth are
true
and i and we have not uh at this point
uh
uh challenged the actions of i've
defended the actions of the prosecutors
in this case in court
uh my the order of business right now
uh is knowing what we know now
uh we don't think any uh of the us
attorneys in the department would have
prosecuted
this case uh partly because of the
behavior of the fbi but also because the
evidence is not there to prove it beyond
a reasonable doubt
and part of what i'm trying to establish
is that we will use the same standards
for everybody
before we indict anybody and this goes
for every both side
uh we won't prosecute anyone anybody
unless there's proof beyond a reasonable
doubt that they committed a crime and
not some kind of esoteric made-up crime
but a meat and potatoes crime uh
for more than three years the most
powerful agencies in our government took
information that was fabricated by
agents of a political campaign that they
knew was fraudulent
used it as justification to launch an
investigation alleging treason
against the presidential candidate then
leaked the existence of that
investigation
in a manner that was clearly calculated
to affect the outcome of the election
and then failing that used it in a
largely successful attempt to obstruct
the duly elected president
are you going to be able to to right
this wrong before it becomes a precedent
for
future election interference by corrupt
officials in our justice and
intelligence agencies
you know i really can't predict that i
think as you know
uh john durham is looking at all these
matters
kovit did delay that action for a while
but he's working very diligently and you
know justice is not something you order
up on a schedule like you're ordering a
pizza
you know there are many of us who are
concerned that if you are succeeded by
someone like keith ellison
as attorney general uh this will become
an institutionalized practice and the
investigation of mr durham will simply
go away
i understand your concern uh one more
thing the term we keep hearing from the
left is oh these are mostly peaceful
protests mostly peaceful
it seems to me that you either are or
you're not
uh calling what's happening in our
cities mostly peaceful
process protest is a lot like calling
scott peterson a mostly faithful husband
or al capone a mostly law-abiding
businessman
there is a constitutional right to
peaceably assemble where does that right
stop when it becomes violence
criminal activity you know and that's
the challenge here i mean
you have a lot of people who are out
protesting and demonstrating and that's
important first amendment activity that
we believe strongly in and
try to protect um and uh
the particular violent opportunists that
are involved here
get into those crowds and then start
engaging in very violent activity
and hijack it and a lot of protesters
have been telling law enforcement
and providing information to us about
these people who are not with them
they're not demonstrators but they're
coming in
and a lot of demonstrators leave when
that happens because they
see what's happening themselves would
you call that violence a myth
gentleman's type no
the gentleman's time has expired mr wu
thank you mr chair thank you mr barr for
being here today
i'd like to ask you some questions about
the legal standard
for seizing and arresting protesters
under the fourth amendment it requires
probable cause before you can seize and
arrest
a protester correct yes
yes okay and
the probable cause has to be
particularized to a particular
person so if a protester was merely
standing around
in a crowd in the vicinity of someone
else
suspected of criminal activity you
cannot arrest that peaceful protester
in other words there's no such thing as
probable cause by mere association
correct well not strictly but i'll i'll
say that you know you do need
particularized probable cause
okay and if there's no probable cause if
someone jumps into a getaway
car and there are three or four people
in there that might be enough to give
you probable cause just those
circumstances
you don't need it on each other they're
claiming my time mr attorney general
if there's no problem cause you can't
arrest and protest it correct
i said at the beginning arrest has to be
predicated on probable cause
all right now an arrest can also occur
whether or not the federal official says
it's an arrest so for example if a photo
officer takes a protester into custody
transfer that protester let's say to a
federal building
detains a person for questioning that
will constitute an arrest
whether or not the federal official says
the person is under arrest correct
that would require a very intensive and
uh review of all the specifics involved
uh actually it wouldn't uh in the case
of dunaway versus new york which is
black letter law for over 40 years
the question is whether the police
violated the 4th and 15th amendments
when
without probable cause or arrest they
took petitioners into custody
transported him to a police station to
detain him from questioning
the answer is yes that would constitute
no the answer is that's
you know fourth amendment is ultimately
governed by reasonableness and
there can be circumstances the question
sometimes is when does something
actually become
cleaning my time i'm site this is not a
trick question
mr barr i'm just citing what the supreme
court said so here's a problem
under this standard black letter law
which has been
in effect over 40 years what the
federal forces in portland did was
unconstitutional
federal forces in full combat year in
the dark of night
grabbed a protester who was peacefully
standing there
forced them into an unmarked van drove
into a separate location
searched him detained him and questioned
him
that is what police states do that's
what authoritarian regime and i don't
think those were the facts that's not
i haven't asked you a question yet mr
barr what the fresh
federal officials did was illegal
because they didn't have probable cause
how do we know that because deputy
director of the federal protector
service chris klein
admitted it on national tv
every director client said that the
individual that they were questioning
was in a crowd in any area where another
individual was aiming a laser at the
eyes of officers
that's guilt by association that's what
the fourth amendment
prohibits deputy director client further
stated that the protester was released
after federal officials concluded
quote they did not have what they needed
unquote which again
shows there's no probable cause and it
appears that
federal uh deputy director client
appears to understand there was no
probable cause because he
essentially justifies that action as
saying it wasn't an arrest he calls it
quote a simple engagement unquote i'm a
former prosecutor i've never heard that
term
a simple engagement because it's a
made-up excuse
what these federal officials did was an
arrest
they grabbed a peaceful protester they
forced him into a van drove him to
another location
questioned him that is exactly what the
supreme court prohibited over 40 years
ago
so obviously i obviously don't know
washington post
i haven't asked you a question yet in a
washington post article on july 24
entitled operation diligent valor
federal agents told reporters that
there's no basis for these arrests
they said quote at times they have
grabbed an individual and taken them
inside the courthouse
for questioning before determining that
they had no probable cause to charge
them with any crime
unquote w directed clients said that
they
coordinate with the u.s attorney's
office on all these arrests
i urge you to instruct your federal
officials to comply with the
constitution
and i ask you to investigate these
arrests because many of them
are in violation of the fourth amendment
we do not live in a police state
we're better than that i yield back
gentlemen yields veterans let's go
thank you mr chair um since
representative liu didn't allow you any
time to
answer his allegations would you care to
answer any of his allegations
yes i mean obviously i i don't know all
the particulars of any individual case
out there but
uh based on my general understanding uh
what had happened
uh was that when they tried to
effectuate arrests
of the ringleaders or the people who
were engaged in violence or that they
saw
with lasers and so forth and they went
out they were immediately swarmed by
people in black and there was a lot of
violence so they couldn't effectuate the
rest
so the modus operandi was changed and
based on
specific information as the individuals
who were seen doing things and
identified
they later tried to pick them up uh when
there was less of a risk of this kind of
mob response
the fact that if you have information
uh that someone has a laser and is using
it
and later pick them up and he doesn't
have it it doesn't mean that there
wasn't probable cause it means he
doesn't have the laser the question
is you know was it reasonable for you to
rely on the information that you had and
the identification of that individual
in some cases it could be a
misidentification in other
cases it could be the person you know
ditched the laser
so there is a distinction between
whether the person ultimately can be
shown
to have violated the law and whether
there was probable cause for the police
to make the inquiry
and and and take them and interrogate
them or ask them questions at least
thank you mr attorney general you know i
think um
i have to tell you you probably know
this my constituents are scared
americans are scared i mean they watch
the tv they see all this rioting
looting going on statues being torn down
in arizona where i'm from more guns are
being sold than ever
i think there's more new gun owners
than ever and uh this has to stop
and i think that it's really important
as the saying goes
that in order to solve a problem the
first step
is to realize there's a problem and so
it always i find it very disturbing
should i say that chairman nadler denies
that antifa even exists he said it to a
reporter
he said on the floor of the united
united states house of representatives
that it was a fantasy a made-up
fantasy uh and then in this very room
just recently congresswoman jay paul who
represents the seattle area said when i
was talking about
the autonomous zone and the takeover
she said the area is just a few miles
from
where i sit right now and there is no
takeover
there is no takeover
she also said lies are being spread by
my colleagues in this committee
this area is perfectly peaceful
um she also said my republican
colleagues
keep saying the seattle police precinct
was
taken over by protesters this is
incorrect
incorrect no one has taken over that
building um mr attorney general is that
your understanding
of what happened there do you agree with
miss j
paul that there was no takeover it was
just jayapal if you're gonna say my name
please say it right
it's jayapal jayapal do you would you
agree with that
and also in answer why do you think
these autonomous zones in democrat-led
cities are dangerous to america
well starting with the uh they're
dangerous because uh
they are purporting to keep on the
outside
uh duly constituted authority of the
government
they're also to me outrageous because
these people the people who are living
now under this
autonomous zone haven't selected the
government
they've selected the duly authorized
government of the city and the state
so it's quite an outrage that that
people would would take
use force to take over an area but what
makes me concerned for the country is
this the first time in my memory
that the leaders of one of our great two
political parties uh
the democratic party are not coming out
and condemning
mob violence and the attack on federal
courts
uh why can't we just say you know the
violence against federal courts has to
stop
could we hear something like that
mr attorney general i totally agree i
support what you're doing and i support
what president trump is doing for law
and order in our country and i yield
back
gentlelady yields back the committee
will stand in recess for five minutes
the committee will uh resume mrs
cicilline
sir in your opening statement you
continue with your sustained
effort to undermine the finding of
russian interference in our election
in march 20 2019 you sent a letter to
the committee mischaracterizing special
counsel robert mueller's finding
that vladimir putin interfered in the
2016 presidential election
in sweeping in systematic fashion to
benefit donald trump
mr mueller promptly sent you a letter
calling you out for your
mischaracterization
and you never corrected it you then
delayed the release of the full report
leaving the american people
stewing with your misleading summary in
support of president trump's bogus
claims
that there was no collusion no
obstruction you repeat these claims
today
there was no basis for this
investigation and it was politically
motivated by calling it the russia gates
scandal
but of course in december 2019 the
justice department's
own inspector general your departments
michael horowitz
found that the investigation had been
initiated properly and without
political bias isn't that correct no
it's not correct that was not mr
horowitz's finding no
he said he said you you are you are
wrong mr trump you know that was
he found the investigation had been
initiated properly
he said he found reclaiming my time
without political
bias he said and in april reclaiming my
time mr attorney
in april of this year the republican-led
senate
intelligence committee unanimously found
that russia interfered with our
elections
and attempted to undermine american
democracy correct
and i said so too is it ever appropriate
to serve for the president to solicit or
accept foreign assistance in an election
it depends what kind of assistance is it
ever
appropriate for the president or
presidential candidate to accept
or solicit foreign assistance of any
kind in his
or her election no it's not appropriate
okay
sorry you had to struggle with that one
mr attorney general now let's turn to
the first amendment
uh americans all across this country
have been exercising their first
amendment rights to peacefully protest
police brutality against black people
i've read your statement i listened to
you this morning and we're certainly
aware of certain individuals who have
engaged in violent acts
and we all agree that's wrong but there
was a lot missing from your statement
for example as i'm sure you've also seen
the vast majority of protesters are
peaceful
and despite that unidentified federal
agents have attempted to prevent these
mothers
veterans and peaceful americans from
exercising their first amendment rights
even using unmarked vehicles to grab
protesters off the street
and using tear gas and munitions against
them you forcefully condemned processors
this morning
but let me ask you sir why have you not
condemned the federal office as you're
sending into cities
without proper training or attempting to
take away the constitution
constitutional rights of americans
peacefully protesting
i haven't condemned protesters
protesters are good
demonstrations are good they're part of
the first amendment
so let me ask what i'm condemning is
people who commit crime yeah we agree do
you think it's ever appropriate mr barr
for officers to use
force against peaceful protesters yes or
no
not against peaceful protest so you also
don't mention in your statement today or
your testimony that federal officers
have even tear-gassed
elected representatives county
commissioner sharon myron confirmed
firsthand
last night i was tear gassed by a
federal occupying force
i saw throw canisters of poison without
warning into a non-violent crowd
including elders and then vulnerable and
on july 23 the mayor ted wheeler was
tear gassed he called the tactics of the
officers
abhorrent these are elected
representatives
with grave concerns that officers are
using abhorrent tactics
including tear-gassing elderly
non-violent americans
so let me ask you sir do you think it's
ever appropriate
to use tear gas on peaceful protesters
yes or no
well the problem in these things
sometimes occur because
uh it's hard to separate people mr barr
my question is very specific
do you think it is ever appropriate to
use tear gas on
peaceful protesters it is yes or no it
is
it is appropriate to use tear gas when
it's indicated
uh to disperse on peaceful processes
unlawful assembly and sometimes
unfortunately
peaceful protesters are affected by okay
now i'm going to show you there's video
evidence
as well i'm going to ask you to look at
this video
that video is of christopher david a
navy veteran
being beaten and tear gas by the offices
do you think that was appropriate
well i didn't see him tear gas i there
seems to be gas in the area i don't know
what kind of gas it was and i don't know
whether it was directed at him
do you think what happened to mr david
was appropriate mr barbara the inspector
general is reviewing that particular
well do you think he deserved to get
pepper sprayed and beaten to the point
of broken bones
as i say the inspector general is going
to review the incident
so as the top law enforcement official
in our country do you think americans
who show up to peacefully protest
should expect to be beaten and pepper
sprayed and have their bones broken by
federal offices
well i don't think that what was
happening immediately around the
courthouse was a peaceful protest
that's not my question mr barr oh that's
where that my question is do you think
as the chief
reclaiming my time reclaiming my time mr
barr
my question is do you think as the top
law enforcement official in this country
that americans who show up to peacefully
protest
should expect to be beaten pepper
sprayed and have their bones broken by
federal officials
yes or no i don't think peaceful
protesters should
should face that that's correct and
isn't protecting the first amendment
freedom of america
at least as important as protecting a
building from vandalism i think
we've fought for i it's not i've not
posed a question we fought for a
democracy for the right to speak freely
and you are attempting to take that away
what's worse you're doing it for the
sole purpose
of furthering the president's political
agenda and generating footage for trump
campaign commercials
the justice department is responsible
for protecting the constitutional rights
of americans
not to serve as the president's personal
bully or political director
and speaking of protesters it's worth
remembering every suffragette
every person who marched to end child
labor every abolitionist who demanded an
end to slavery was a protester
the revolutionaries who transformed us
from colonists into a nation
were protesters protesters aren't chaos
they're deeply american examples of
values a desire for this country to be
at its best self
they're righteous sometimes there's
necessary one of america's most beloved
and effective protesters
john lewis lies in state a thousand feet
from here
in a deserved place of honor and sir
your failure to respect the role of
peaceful protest
in this country is a disgrace it's
un-american and it's important to
remember what these protests are about
black lives matter abuse at the hands of
police by black americans and i want to
let you see now a video that fairly
represents
peaceful protest that is happening all
across america that you conveniently
omitted from your testimony and your
statement
there was a nine minute video shown by
the other side so i
it's not all nine only part of it
true
me
please
mr mr chairman gentlemen mr just just
real quick i don't think we've i don't
think we've ever had a hearing where
the witness wasn't allowed to respond
to points made questions asked and
attacks
attacks made every not just in this
hearing not just in this committee but
every community have been on
particularly particularly when you think
about the fact we got the attorney
general the united states here
gentlemen does not have the time i don't
want the time i just want i want the
attorney general to be able to have
enough time to respond to accusations
and questions ask him
and you guys not cut him off what you
want is irrelevant
but irrelevant of the rules mr stooby is
recognized
uh mr chairman am i going to get an
additional two and a half minutes that
mr sisolini had
the gentleman is recognized
general barr thank you for your service
to our country and your continued
service to ensure that our country is
safe
i encourage you to ignore the mob these
attacks from democrats and the left-wing
am i going to get an additional two and
a half minutes that mr cicilline had
the gentleman is recognized
general barr thank you for your service
to our country and your continued
service to ensure that our country is
safe
i encourage you to ignore the mob these
attacks from democrats in the left-wing
bias mainstream media
be strong and courageous for the mass
majority of the country supports you and
supports you
rooting out corruption in the fbi and
keeping our country safe from rioters
looters and anarchists i for one am very
happy that you're at the helm of the doj
and actually supporting the rule of law
and fighting for justice
i want to touch on something that mr
jordan spoke about in his opening
remarks i want to focus on the inspector
general's december
9th fisa report on the fbi's unlawful
surveillance of trump campaign associate
carter page
isn't it true the inspector general
found the fbi under the obama biden
administration
made 17 significant errors in fisa
applications to surveil
candidate trump's campaign associate
carter page
i think that's right how many errors are
acceptable when the fbi is targeting
americans well none are acceptable
then there was the complete woods files
failures the fbi operated under during
the obama advised administration
the inspector general found that 51
factual assertions
in the fisa applications to surveil page
1
black supporting documentation 2 the
supporting document did not support the
fbi's factual assertions
or 3 the supporting document showed the
fbi's factual assertion
was inaccurate the inspector general
testified there should not have even
been one error yet he found
51 heirs why is it so important for
surveillance targeting americans to be
error-free
well especially under under fisa which
um
you know is a counterintelligence tool
and doesn't have the same
built-in protections that the criminal
justice process would have
it's very important because you're going
to be
spying on americans that you haven't uh
you know you've demonstrated an
appropriate basis for doing that
and uh therefore there's a special
burden
uh on the investigative agency in this
case the fbi
to have accurate information as to the
basis of their surveillance
and you know i think the bureau is has
been working very hard to
correct those problems and to put in
place a much
more uh effective system of guaranteeing
that the information is accurate
isn't it true the fbi under the obama
biden administration
cherry-picked favorable evidence to
obtain a fisa warrant
to surveil carter page and ignore facts
that cut against probable cause
well i don't want to characterize i mean
that this is uh part of
what's under review uh
some exculpatory information was not
passed along to the court let me just
put it that way that's
evident in the inspector general's
report
i will yield the remainder of my time to
mr jordan
the gentleman for for yielding um mr
attorney general do you
do you deploy federal law enforcement to
enforce federal law yes
do you deploy federal law enforcement to
protect federal property
yes would the federal building in
portland be standing today if you had
not deployed
federal law enforcement i don't think so
there have been multiple attempts to set
it a fire yeah
and i can i you know have to say i don't
understand why a small contingent of
marshals
inside the court poses a threat to
anybody's first amendment rights
they set up a fence on federal property
i am told
around the court and when people are
arrested it's because they're trying to
come
into the uh fence these aren't peaceful
protesters they bring power tools to cut
through the wire and so forth to get in
this is a very strange occupation of a
city when you have
you know 100 120 federal people behind
the fence trying to protect the building
and all these people are trying to cut
their way in
that is the occupation of the city
thank you um did the chicago fraternal
order
uh fraternal order of police chi or
president
um asked for your help did who asked for
my help
the head of the fop in chicago did they
ask for your help
i think he did i think he did um
previous exchange they talked about mr
horowitz's report
um is there anything you'd like to add
you didn't get a chance to respond to
that
yeah my understanding of uh my
recollection of the report is it
didn't find there was no bias uh it and
he made that clear the
subsequent testimony what he said was he
couldn't find no documentary or other
evidence
demonstrating bias yeah and what would
be helpful if maybe mr horowitz could
come in front of this committee and the
individual who was raising that concern
with you mr attorney general could ask
mr horowitz himself
about what he found in that report and
subsequent reports that we have not yet
had a hearing on the gentleman's time
has expired mr askin
thank you sir did i hear you correctly
to say that the purpose of
unleashing this federal agent assault
with tear gas and rubber bullets and
pepper spray
on 2 000 non-violent protesters in
lafayette square
was to secure and defend the saint
john's episcopal church
was that the purpose of it no i didn't
say that i made very clear
that the purpose was to move the
perimeter to high street
which had been the point as far as i'm
aware all day
before so it was legitimate in that case
talking about the june 1st
yeah the june first assault on a lot of
what was putting my constituents
including my constituents and
bring them to your audience to talk okay
well i don't think it was an assault
they were
told by loudspeaker that the park police
were preparing to clear
h street and could they move without
faith straight reclaiming my time i
think you said something to the effect
of the saint john's episcopal church
would have been over
that was on sunday on sunday night i
believe okay
are you aware that director of the
church that the episcopal archbishop of
washington
and the presiding bishop of the
episcopal church nationally along with
the catholic bishop of the archdiocese
of washington all denounced this police
assault
on the civil rights and civil liberties
of the people did they do that before or
after the fire was put
well all that all that i know is that
they denounced
what you did and if you read what the
archbishop
the episcopal archbishop of washington
wrote
said that using police force to clear
non-violent protesters without notice
in order to conduct this grotesque photo
opportunity was antithetical
antithetical to the principles of
christianity but what i want to ask you
about was covid19
because we now lead the world in covid19
case count
and death count president trump of
course promised the disease would
magically disappear he advertised
quack medical cures like injecting
people with disinfectant
he told his people to slow down all the
testing and refuse for months to wear a
mask
last night he retweeted a number of
messages claiming that dr fauci misled
the american people
by dismissing hydroxychloroquine as a
cure for the disease so now we have
150 000 dead americans 4 million
infected
40 million jobless we lose more than a
thousand people
every day one american every 90 seconds
but you called his public health
leadership superb
and you threw the weight of the justice
department behind his campaign
to shut down state public health orders
in march and april
now if you look at the screen you will
see two tweets from
the president of the united states
liberate michigan
liberate virginia on april 17th
he retweeted the slogans of right-wing
protesters
that are blocking access to hospitals
and trying to overthrow
public health orders in those states and
you snapped attention on april 27th you
designated
a prosecutor to try to bring down those
very public health orders
in michigan and virginia two days later
armed right-wing protesters and white
supremacists disrupted the michigan
legislature
leveling death threats against governor
whitmer confronting police
taunting lawmakers and forcing the
legislature to shut down
as they brandished their long guns and
shouted in
your motions for emergency injunctions
but you got to spread trump's message
that it was time to call off the
stay-at-home orders
the masking and social distancing here's
what you said on national tv
echoing the claim in april that the cure
was worse than the disease
quote you can't just keep on feeding the
patient
chemotherapy and say well we're killing
the cancer
because we were getting to the point
where we're killing the patient
do you remember saying that yeah what do
you mean by that
exactly what it says you have to balance
the cure with the
with the danger which we leave to
governors you know and i know everyone
likes you know
i know everyone likes to lay everything
but this is a federal republic and the
president respected that
and our responsibility and our response
has been largely
run by governors now for someone who
claims to be so concerned about
executive
overreach i haven't heard anyone talk
about just keeping an eye on what the
governor's doing mr board would know
that that's
all the department of excuse me it's the
area of religious liberty
the supreme court rejected your position
on religious liberty five before and
said there was nothing wrong
with applying public health orders to
churches that was on an injunction
did you accept that or you don't accept
it uh well we'll talk about it later
mr bart with no vaccine no treatment no
cure in sight
you work to disarm the states of the
only weapon we have against this disease
public health measures and now we pay
the price of this policy
in overrun intensive care units and
morgues a shortage of coffins and
refrigerated trucks
and an out of control pandemic which
makes us a global pariah state
whose citizens cannot enter dozens of
foreign countries including canada do
you know what dr
fauci was saying at the same time we pay
the price of this policy
in overrun intensive care units and
morgues a shortage of coffins and
refrigerated trucks
and an out of control pandemic which
makes us a global pariah state
whose citizens cannot enter dozens of
foreign countries including canada
do you know what dr fauci was saying at
the same time that you were moving to
take down those public health orders
here's what dr fauci was warning us
about three months ago
about the premature abandonment of
health orders if only you had listened
he said
i feel if that occurs there is a real
risk you will trigger an
outbreak and you may not be able to
control it which in fact
we're not taking down public health
orders we were making narratives
we were calling attention will you
restore my time because this witness
isn't speaking over time
he's trying to gentlemen's time is
mr expired the gentleman is recognized
thank you mr chairman we do have a
governor in virginia who is engaged in
overreach particularly regarding the
civil rights of
virginians and their expression of their
religious faith so i want to give the
attorney general the opportunity to
respond
to the right gentleman from maryland we
we
adopted a very narrow approach of
calling to the attention
usually by letter not by lawsuit of
uh situations where they were treating
religion worse than they were
other kinds of organizations and
gatherings and the constitution requires
that it be treated the same
and we were calling those to the
attention of the governors and most of
the governors that we called attention
to
voluntarily change their own orders
there were a few occasions where we
pointed out
anomalies in the regulation differential
regulation of business
and again mostly they were voluntarily
changed by the governors
so this was not a wholesale attack on
stay at home orders it was just that
these are very broad powers that have
been seated you know basically telling
everyone to stay at home and only work
if you're an essential business and so
forth and therefore
someone has to keep an eye on that and
make sure there's no overreach and as
time went by there were
there were times where uh you know that
you had these crazy rules in effect
uh that were overly burdensome and raise
constitutional problems
i want to thank you for raising those
points early and
particularly with regard to virginia and
the church
out on the eastern shore i want to thank
you also for being here and for
returning to lead the department of
justice and right the ship and root out
the rank partisanship and bias that had
corrupted the administration of justice
for many years the democrats allege that
attorney general barr has politicized
the justice department doing the
personal bidding of president trump but
it's not only unfounded it's especially
hypocritical in light of the
politicization that occurred during the
obama biden administration
and uh led by president obama's
self-described wing man
attorney general eric holder the obama
biden justice department investigated
journalists
shut out career prosecutors and flouted
congressional oversight
i want to ask particularly
even after president trump assumed
office fbi lawyers exhibited bias
against trump while working for both
mueller and the fbi's russia
investigation
and the inspector general couldn't rule
out political animus against candidate
trump as influencing
fbi abuse correct that's my
understanding
um the inspector general found that an
fbi lawyer altered evidence to support a
fice application to surveil carter page
and criminally referred this lawyer to
durham for federal prosecution
the same lawyer who also worked on the
investigations into clinton's misuse
classified information in russia
collusion expressed bias against
president trump and the inspector
general testified
back in december that he can't rule out
bias mr attorney general i'd asked what
would the consequences be to one of your
justice department lawyers if they
doctored
underlying documents so they could
support evidence submitted to a federal
court
um you know in the in the abstract
talking generally
that lawyer would be fired would they
likely be disbarred as well
yes and isn't it true that the ig found
that an fbi lawyer doctored an email to
support probable cause against candidate
trump's campaign aide
i think that's right and the same fbi
lawyer
worked on the russia investigation
targeting
candidate trump's campaign and was on
the special counsel mueller team
investigating president trump correct
i'm not sure about that and while
working on those investigations the
inspector
general found several texts showing that
animus correct
on that particular lawyer i believe so
yes
i can't remember the time frame of the
text but i i know there were other texts
let me talk to you about the uh
unmasking that occurred
where mr grinnell released a list of 39
officials who submitted a request to
unmask the identity
of general flynn from november 8th 2016
to january 13th 31st
2017. 49 requests first were submitted
is that a normal number of requests for
unmasking i mean historically that's a
that
seems to be a high number and and the
other question you have to ask is why
why was this after the election
and seven treasury officials including
secretary
of the treasury jacob lew deputy
secretary sarah raskin
is that a normal occurrence
uh you know there are times where
high-level officials
can do it i i you know don't know enough
about the specifics they can yield the
remainder of my time to mr jordan
mr attorney general what's more
important going to church or going to a
protest
it depends on the individual both
covered under the first amendment right
right yeah what's more important going
to work or going to a protest
again it depends on the individual you
know we're all free we can all make our
choices
i'm talking about government limits on
those activities
what's more important government putting
limits on protesting our government's
putting limit on attending church
are there both first amendments exactly
right exactly and we should treat them
the same shouldn't we
gentlemen's time has expired mr ayapal
mr barr on june 1st there were protests
against the murder of george floyd
and police brutality in lafayette park
let us
not be distracted by you or my gop
colleagues
as to what these powerful and massive
protests were actually about
they were about the persistent killing
of black bodies
by law enforcement and finally finally
an awakening in america of the
conscience
of our country and yet your response mr
barr was to direct federal
officers to close in on the protesters
and to use shields offensively as
weapons
tear gas pepper balls irritants
explosive devices
batons and horses to clear the area just
so the president
could get a photo of so i do want to ask
you do you think
that your response do you think the
response at lafayette square
to tear gas pepper spray and beat and
protesters and injure american citizens
who were
just simply uh exercising their first
amendment rights was appropriate
well first it's my understanding that no
tear gas was used on monday june 1st
mr barr that is a semantic distinction
that has been proven
false by many fact checkers how is it do
you think how is it semantic tear gas is
a particular comment you talked about
chemical irritants
and it has been proven false by reports
so
just answer the question do you think
that it is appropriate
at lafayette park to pepper spray
tear gas and beat protesters and injure
american citizens
well i don't accept your
characterization of what happened but as
i explained
the effort there was mr barr i just
asked
yes or no so let me just tell you i'm
starting to lose my temper
according to sworn testimony before the
house natural resources committee
by army national guard officer adam
demarco who was there
this was quote an unprovoked escalation
and excessive use of force against
peaceful protesters
numerous i don't really remember demarco
as being mr bart
sir sir the president told governors on
a telephone call that the way to deal
with the protesters of police brutality
and systemic racism like in lafayette
square
is that quote you have to get much
tougher you have to dominate
if you don't dominate you're wasting
your time
these are terrorists and he also talked
about you on that call
sir here's what he said he said the
attorney general is here
bill barr and we will activate bill barr
and activate him strongly do you
remember that call mr barr
yes i did but he wasn't talking about
protesters he was talking mr barr
apparently the president believes that
you can be activated to implement the
president's agenda and
dominate american people exercising
first amendment rights
if they're protesting against him but
let's look at how you respond
when the protesters are supporters of
the president
on two separate occasions after
president
trump tweeted liberate michigan to
subvert
stay home orders to protect the public
health of people
in michigan protesters swarmed the
michigan capitol carrying
guns some with swastikas confederate
flags
and one even with a dark-haired doll
with a noose
around its neck are you aware that these
protesters called for the governor
to be lynched shot and beheaded
no you're not aware of that i was not
aware major protests
in michigan you're the attorney general
and you didn't know
that the protesters called for the
governor to be lynched
shot and beheaded so obviously you
couldn't be concerned about that
well there are a lot of protests around
the united states and
uh on june 1st i was worried about the
district of columbia which protests
in certain parts of the country you're
very aware of those but when
protesters with guns and swastikas i am
you are aware of certain kinds of
protesters but in michigan
when protesters carry guns and
confederate flags
and swastikas and call for the governor
of michigan to be beheaded and shot and
lynched
somehow you're not aware of that somehow
you didn't know about it so you didn't
send federal agents in
to do to the president's supporters what
you did
to the president's protesters in fact
you didn't you didn't put pepper balls
on those protesters
so the point i'm trying to make here mr
barr that i think is very important for
the country to understand
is that there is a real discrepancy in
how
you react as the attorney general the
top cop in this country
when white men with swastikas storm a
government building
with guns there is no need for the
president to quote
activate you because they're getting the
president's personal agenda done
but when black people and people of
color
protest police brutality systemic racism
and the president's very own lack of
response to those critical issues
then you forcibly remove them with armed
federal
officers pepper bombs because they are
considered
terrorists by the president you take an
aggressive approach to black lives
matter protests
but not to right-wing extremists
threatening to lynch the governor
if it's for the trump's if it's for the
president's benefit don't get it right
mr barr
i have responsibility for the federal
government
in the white house as the seat of the mr
bar let me just make it clear
you are supposed to the michigan
authorities can handle
of the united states of america not
violate people's first amendment rights
you are supposed to uphold them